Paderborn muss sich nach einer 2-0-Führung noch Schalke mit 2 zu 3 geschlagen geben und nach diesem Wochenende haben wir eventuell unseren ersten Absteiger in die 3. Liga besiegelt. Wir sprechen über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer nach dem 31. Spieltag mit Anna Lautenbach und Thorsten Wiese und jetzt geht's los. Nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Lagerflieg vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor! Und Augsburg ist oben!
Rossi zu Kurzabwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf! Wagner, Martin Wagner! Und das als Sonne. Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl. Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Herzlich willkommen zur Ligatur, zur 2. Bundesliga, der Männer. Schön, dass ihr wieder eingeschaltet habt. Es ist Ende April, das heißt, wir sind auch alle langsam, aber sicher mit unseren Nerven am Ende dieser Liga. Mein Name ist Eva Lottabohle. Ich sage es, wie es ist, es war ein, also seit dem letzten Mal ist hier bei mir gemütstechnisch viel passiert. Ich glaube, bei meinen beiden Gästen auch. Falls ihr euch freut darüber, dass diese Sendung stattfindet und warum ihr denkt, okay, falls ihr die Bundesliga Sendung der Männer gehört habt, die gehört hat, das stand ein bisschen in der Schwebe. Nein, ich habe nicht so viel gefeiert am Wochenende. Ich sah einfach nur kurzfristig aus wie Rudolf und habe mich damit so einfach ein bisschen in der Jahreszeit vergriffen. Das ist zum Glück gut für alle Zuschauerinnen, wenn ihr so einen roten Punkt auf meiner Nase seht. Ich habe auch keine drei Flaschen Schnapps vor dieser Aufnahme getrunken, um irgendwie durchzukommen. Man weiß es nicht so ganz, woran es liegt und vielleicht ist das auch schon mal ein gutes Stichwort. Für so ein paar Punkte in dieser Folge, woran hat es gelegen. Aber nach der Folge der schlechten Laune bei den drei Mitgliedern der letzten Folge, darf ich heute zur Folge der guten Laune begrüßen und damit back-to-back auch Anna Lautenbach vom Gegengratepodcast hier begrüßen. Hallo, Anna.
Hallo. Ja, in der Tat. Ganz andere Stimmung, ganz anderer Vibe als vor zwei Wochen.
Ja, falls ihr das eben nicht nur hört, sondern auch seht, ihr seht Anna's Strahlen im Gesicht. Also die Laune, sie ist auf jeden Fall da. Und als hätte die Fortuna gesagt, ach, der Thorsten, der ist im Rasenfunk zu Gast. Da schenken wir ihm doch einfach mal einen Sieg. Von daher, herzlich Willkommen, Thorsten Wiese vom Gebrammel Rot-Weiß-Podcast. Schön, dass du auch mal wieder dabei bist.
Ja, hallo, vielen Dank. Tatsächlich bin ich noch ungeschlagen in meinem Rasenfunk-Besuchen. Es ist jetzt, glaube ich, das vierte Mal und ich bin immer ohne Niederlage bisher gekommen. Also, so gesehen, ganz gut. Ich wollte aber es eigentlich mit Reporterlegende Günter Koch halten und sagen, ja, willkommen vom Abgrund. Und das trifft auf uns alle so ein bisschen zu, ne?
Ja, aber vielleicht der Abgrund mit so ein bisschen, bisschen mehr Sicherheit in den Beinen.
Abgrund oder Aussicht, ne? Das ist ja auch alles eine freie Perspektive.
Genau, wir haben alle so einen Schritt zurück gemacht.
Am Grand Canyon der 2. Liga stehen wir auf der sicheren Seite.
Kleiner Sundowner.
Ja, voll die Titel, ne? Am Grand Canyon der 2. Liga.
Oh Gott. Naja, bevor wir uns weiter in hier irgendwelche merkwürdigen Metaphern und Bildsprache, weiß ich nicht, verlaufen, eine kleine Übersicht darüber, was ihr euch in dieser Folge erwartet. Wir werden natürlich gleich als allererstes über die Lage der Liga sprechen. Ihr kennt es schon. Und dann haben wir uns für 4 Vereine entschieden. Es gibt bestimmt jetzt 14 andere Vereine, die sagen, ja, aber warum denn nicht mein Verein und so? Das liegt einfach daran, dass wir uns vorher natürlich irgendwie auf 4 Vereine einigen mussten und wo wir dachten, da gäbe es potenziell vielleicht über was, worüber wir reden müssen und über Vereine, über die wir halt von vor zwei Wochen nicht geredet haben. Und genau, das ist so ein bisschen der Grund, warum uns die, vor allem ich, mir die 4 Vereine rausgesucht habe. Ich möchte jetzt auch nicht die Verantwortung auf meine beiden Gästinnen hier abschieben. Es ist vor allem meine Auswahl gewesen. Und bei der Lage der Liga, habe ich ja eben schon gesagt, haben wir hier einen sehr, sehr gut gelaunten Thorsten sitzen. Und das liegt vor allem daran, dass Fortuna Düsseldorf am Freitagabend 3 zu 1 gegen Dynamo Dresden gewinnen konnte. Und naja, nachdem das erste Spiel unter Alex Ende, ich sage mal vorsichtig, gar nicht mal so viel versprechend aussah und der Abgrund dann doch noch ein bisschen anders war. Thorsten, was war denn für dich so der Hauptgrund am Freitagabend? Warum hat die Fortuna dieses Spiel gewonnen?
Ja, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Alex Ende übrigens damit mit einer 50% Siegquote. Welcher Trainer kann das schon von sich verhaufen? Ja, was war anders? Die Einstellung war anders. Und das klingt jetzt wahrscheinlich für viele Teams, die lange im Abstiegskampf sind, verwunderlich. Aber tatsächlich ist es so, dass Fortuna Düsseldorf lange Zeit diese Saison– und ehrlicherweise ist das Thema immer noch ein bisschen zu überprüfen– also den Ernst der Lage, die Ausstrahlung, dass man diesen Ernst der Lage verstanden hat, das hat Fortuna Düsseldorf lange vermissen lassen. So auch leider im ersten Spiel unter Alexander Ende in Magdeburg, das relativ sang- und klanglos und wirklich hochverdient verloren ging. Und allen in Düsseldorf war wirklich Angst und Bange, inklusive mir in der letzten Woche. Aber es ging auf der anderen Seite auch so ein gewisser Ruck durch den Verein. Es gab viele Schulterschlüsse zwischen Fans und Mannschaft, gab es nochmal Treffen. Auf der Geschäftsstelle wurde sich eingeschworen, denn machen wir uns nichts vor, ein Drittliga-Abstieg von einem Verein, der auch administrativ so breit aufgestellt ist wie Fortuna Düsseldorf, hat große personelle Konsequenzen, die er mit sich bringen würde. Und da sind natürlich auch tatsächlich viele Leute hinter den Kulissen von Betroffen. Das heißt, da wurde viel gesprochen. Es wurde noch mal versucht, das Thema so ein bisschen zu pushen, natürlich auch vom Trainerteam. Und selbst am Tag des Spiels selber gab es ein Spalier von allen Angestellten, die gerade nicht bei der Arbeit waren etc. Also es wurden wirklich alle Registerkarten gezogen, die man in so einem Fall ziehen kann. Ja, aber es hat ja auch was gebracht. Also wer gewinnt hat rechts, ist doch glaube ich das alte Sprichwort. Jetzt ist nur die Frage, wie ist das eigentlich passiert? Wenn man sich nämlich so ein bisschen die Zahlen anguckt, dann sieht man erstmal, ja, Dresden mit zwei Drittel Prozent Ballbesitz, etc. Das klingt jetzt nicht nach so souverän. Und ja, tatsächlich täuschen da hier und da die statistischen Werte. Fortuna hat Dresden durchaus absichtlich den Ball überlassen. Und das verwundert ja auch erstmal, wenn man Alexander Ende so ein bisschen verfolgt hat in Münster. Und ihr habt ja auch vor zwei Wochen ihn so ein bisschen charakterisiert als Trainer. Und da war viel die Rede von Raute, Ballbesitz, Fußball, Kurzpassspiel, etc. Und es wurde ja auch so ein bisschen dieser Vorwurf laut, dass er in Münster da ein bisschen zu dogmatisch vielleicht hier und da dran festgehalten hatte. Das war allerdings am Freitag ein komplett pragmatischer Ansatz. Und der hat zum Erfolg geführt. Denn Dresden spielt, wie wir alle wissen, eine wirklich herausragende Rückrunde. Ist richtig stark. Ich glaube, Führt ist das Rückrundenteam aktuell. Aber eine Schwäche, die man bei ihnen vielleicht feststellen kann, ist, sie sind kein Ballbesitzteam. Also kein Team, das einen Gegner, der massiv hinten drin steht, bearbeiten kann. Sie kommen viel über Umschaltspiel, brauchen diese Momente. Die hatten sie hier und da auch in Düsseldorf. Aber es hat sich doch ein bisschen gezeigt, dass, wenn sie vor allem mit dem Ball agieren müssen und dann natürlich auch einen Rückstand schnell hinterherlaufen, also das Spielglück spielte definitiv eine Rolle durch die frühe Führung von Itten und dann kurz danach den Eckball, den man aber, wie Ende auch gesagt hatte, genau in dieser Form auch trainiert hatte tatsächlich. Ich hoffe dann auch ohne das Abfälschen, aber okay, das lassen wir mal so stehen. Auf jeden Fall kam also dieses Beides letztendlich zusammen. Dresden hatte den Ball, wusste nicht wirklich, was damit anzufangen. Und Fortuna kam vor allem über den Einsatz. Also man ist mehr gelaufen als Dresden, man hat sich in die Zweikämpfe geworfen. Tatsächlich, wie ich es von dieser Mannschaft so noch nicht gesehen habe in dieser Saison. Und das war am Ende der Schlüssel zum Erfolg. Dresden hatte vielleicht immer so kleine Schöngschen, wenn man sich dann so die XG-Werte anguckt. Dann ist ja auch ein bisschen höher bei Dresden. Aber wenn man sich das Spiel auch mal so eine Highlights-Zusammenfassung angeguckt hat, dann muss man sagen, die besseren Chancen waren eigentlich schon auf Fortunas Seite und die wurden diesmal natürlich auch ganz gut genutzt. Es gab aber noch einen Lackenkopfball etc. Aber das hat also funktioniert. Jetzt wurde wirklich ganz gut gearbeitet.
Ganz kurz, ganz Thorsten, genau. Weitergehen, einmal kurz, Anna, dich auch reinholend. Thorsten hat es eben schon gesagt, Dresden Platz 4 in der Rückrunde. Vor dieser Partie eigentlich auch die beste Defensive in der Rückrunde. Also das waren jetzt Gegentore. Also man hat jetzt 16 Gegentore in 14 Partien. Eben die drei dazugekommen. Jetzt von diesem Spiel. Hat dich das so ein bisschen überrascht, dass Dresden so ein bisschen, ja ich würde ja schon sagen, die Effizienz, die sie ja sonst zuletzt auf den Rasen auch gelegt haben, so ein bisschen gefehlt hat in diesem Spiel?
Ja, also zum einen hat Dresden meine Hoffnung enttäuscht. Nicht für ungut, Thorsten, aber ich hatte so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass eine gewisse Dynamik, also den Abstiegskampf scheidet. Und habe ehrlich gesagt gedacht, dass Dresden sich da nicht die Butter vom Brot nehmen lassen wird. Ich habe nur die Zusammenfassung gesehen, weil ich parallel im Stadion war und sein durfte. Ich hatte so ein bisschen in der Zusammenfassung Erinnerung an die Hinrunde, an die Dresdner Hinrunde, weil die ja eigentlich nie schlecht aufgetreten sind. Auch die beschmäßigen Ergebnisse vor diesen hervorragenden Wintertransfers, die sie getätigt haben, haben ja nicht widergespiegelt. Dahinter stand keine schlechte Leistung, kein ratloses Spiel. Daran hatte ich mich so ein bisschen erinnert gefühlt. Also zum einen das Unglück im Abschluss oder so ein bisschen fehlende Präzision, wofür das Team seit dem Winter nicht mehr unbedingt steht. Was mich aber vor allem überrascht hat, war vielleicht symptomatisch eben das 1-0, wie das zustande kommt. Also dieser weite Abschlag von Carsten Mayer auf Itten, wahrscheinlich sowieso das Traumpaar des Spieltags, wirklich ja fantastisch und ja auch noch an anderen Momenten miteinander agiert. Und dass das failt, dass da irgendwie die Restverteidigung so dürftig ist, hat mich extrem überrascht, weil das eigentlich, finde ich, eine Szene ist, über die ich mich jetzt nicht wundern würde, wenn Dresden irgendwie in der 83. Minute einen 2-0 aufholen muss und möchte. Und dass das beim 0-0 irgendwie, dass man sich da so überrumpeln lässt, weiß ich nicht, hat mich überrascht. Aber vielleicht ist es eben auch darauf zurückzuführen, dass sie auf was anderes eingestellt waren, dass sie irgendwie gedacht haben, die Fortuna spielt zu Hause, Ende steht eher für Ballbesitz, dass sie nicht mit Konterfußball gerechnet haben.
Ja, finde ich auf jeden Fall sehr interessant. Und Anna, du bist dann natürlich nicht mit alleine. Also wir haben auch schon bei uns in der All-Star-Team-Gruppe gesagt, im Abstiegskampf und in der Liebe ist alles erlaubt.
Das ist wirklich nichts Persönliches.
Wirklich, da guckt man auch mal anders. Ich glaube, wir hatten alle, also ich kann es schon mal spoilern. Meine Laune war Freitagabend zwischenzeitlich sehr schlecht nach diesen beiden Partien, die für euch beide ja sehr gut ausgegangen sind. Meine Laune war Freitagabend suboptimal, möchte ich. Also ich saß auf dem Sofa und ich hatte wirklich meine Lust aufs Derby am nächsten Tag lag bei minus 18 so ungefähr. Also ich glaube, das kennen wir auch alle so ein bisschen. Aber Thorsten, um dich wieder reinzuholen, du hast gerade ja noch so mit einem Satz gesagt, es war so Fußball gearbeitet. Glaubst du denn, das war jetzt so ein Quick-Fix für das eine Spiel oder das ist jetzt was, was man, man muss ja sagen, man hat jetzt irgendwie noch mal ein Spiel ganz am Ende des Spieltags, wo man vielleicht da diesen, das noch mal hinbekommen könnte, gegen die Spielvereinigung führt. Gegen Schalke und Elversberg, ja gegen Schalke wird man jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt auch wahnsinnig viel Beibesitz haben, aber da bleibt ja auch– meinst du, das ist jetzt generell eine Taktik, die könnte jetzt aufgehen für die restlichen Spieler auch, weil man muss ja auch sagen, also diese drei Punkte alleine isoliert dir ja natürlich relativ wenig, wenn du in den kommenden Spielen dann wieder nichts holst.
Ich glaube, wenn wir auf die nächsten zwei Gegner gucken, und das ist eben jetzt Schalke auswärts, da wird das ganze Land hingucken, glaube ich, auf die Partie, und dann zu Hause gegen Elversberg, dann ist das wahrscheinlich schon ein veritabler Ansatz, auch für diese beiden Partien. Schalke ist jetzt zwar deutlich verbessert im Ballbesitz in der Rückrunde, aber immer noch nicht, sagen wir mal, eine Mannschaft, die unfassbar gerne den Ball möchte. Und ich glaube, gegen Elversberg hat man gar nicht eine andere Wahl, als da eher defensiv anzutreten, weil man, wenn man da das offene Visier sucht, wahrscheinlich ganz böse auf die Nase mitfallen kann. Darum, ich glaube, ja, mein Gefühl sagt mir auch, dass das, ja, also jetzt auch klappen könnte. Für mich ist das natürlich jetzt eine spannende Situation nächsten Samstag. Ich möchte ehrlicherweise, also gleich mal vorausschicken, dass der Aufstieg von Schalke wirklich mehr als verdient ist. Und ich glaube, es gibt auch keinen mehr daran zweifelt. Aber ich gebe zu, ich muss das jetzt nicht unbedingt, wenn es für den eigenen Verein um alles geht, muss ich das jetzt nicht live im Stadion erleben. Da bin ich ehrlicherweise ein bisschen besorgt. Ich hoffe also, dass die Schalke das einfach eine Woche später bei ihren Freunden in Nürnberg machen. Das wäre doch wunderbar. Ansonsten, aber ich muss sagen, es ist natürlich jetzt ein Spiel gewesen, das hast du vollkommen zu Recht rausgearbeitet. Und ich will nicht sagen, dass ich den Braten noch nicht traue, aber eine Bestätigung, die wäre mir schon wichtig dafür. Und die hat es noch nicht gegeben. Wir haben jetzt ein erstes, relativ schlechtes Spiel unter Ende gesehen. Ein zweites mit dem Ansatz durchaus überzeugendes. Und jetzt ist die spannende Frage, was auf Schalke passieren wird. Ehrlicherweise hat man aber sehr wenig, also natürlich hat man Druck, dass man gerade Punkte braucht. Aber die Erwartungshaltung gegen Dresden war ganz klar, wenn heute nichts passiert, dann können wir den Laden zumachen. Während auf Schalke glaube ich viele ein Verständnis dafür haben, wenn das Spiel vielleicht dann nicht gewonnen wird. Und aus der Perspektive, wer weiß. Das ist so mein Ansatz. Ich habe das Gefühl, es läuft wirklich auf ein Finale von der letzten Spieltage in Fürth, 500 is Love hinaus. Brauche ich jetzt auch nicht. Das ist alles sehr anstrengend. Das ist ja fast jede Woche wie ein Relegationsspiel. Die steht ja übrigens auch noch im Raum dann, theoretisch.
Wir haben, glaube ich, alle unsere Erfahrungen mit Relegation gemacht. Wir sind alle kein Fan. Kann ich, glaube ich. Einwandfrei. Also Menschen, die Fan von der Relegation sind. Da habe ich sowieso Fragen, was ihr sonst noch so mögt. Also nicht.
Die interessieren sich nicht für einzelne Fußballvereine, sondern für den Sport als solches wahrscheinlich.
Ja, aber mögt ihr auch Marmelade unter Fisch?
Interessanter Vergleich.
Aber jetzt mal ganz ehrlich. Na ja, wir hatten ja noch ein, zwei andere Partien am Wochenende. Und eine Partie, ja, die vielleicht nicht von der Formkurve des Vereins, aber durchaus vom Spielverlauf ein bisschen überraschend war. Das war der 1 zu 0 Sieg von Einstein Kiel bei Hertha BSC. Und also ich glaube, in den letzten Monaten gab es weniger Spiele, die denen wirklich diesen Satz, Fußball ist ein Ergebnis, Sport, so ad absurdum geführt haben wie dieses Spiel. Weil also guckt euch einfach die Zusammenfassung der Sportschau an. Es war wirklich irgendwie alles dabei, was als neutraler Fan vielleicht noch ganz witzig ist. Aber ich glaube gerade als Hertha Fan wolltest du einfach wirklich nur in irgendwas reinbeißen am Wochenende. Also eigentlich eine drückende Überlegenheit der Hertha. Genau das, was leider die ganze Saison ja irgendwie ein Problem ist. Und das ist einfach die Chancenverwertung. Aber dann halt auch wirklich, also 11 Meter, der nicht gegeben wird, wegen einer Upside-Stellung, wo ich wirklich fragen muss, naja, das war in der, also, ist das wirklich im Sinne der Regelauslegung deshalb einen 11 Meter nicht zu geben? Ich glaube, wir sind, ich sag schon mal, ich glaube, wir sind uns da alle einig. Aber ja, also ich meine, einen positiven Satz vielleicht noch zu Holschankiel und dann gucken wir mal ganz kurz auf diese Spiele. Man hat jetzt 13 Punkte aus den letzten fünf Spielen geholt. Nur Schalke 04 ist besser in der Formkurve. Also man hat eben genau das geschafft, was du da unten brauchst, nämlich in der Formkurve einfach wirklich stabil zu bleiben. Anna, ich frage mal dich als erstes. Das war aber schon wirklich ein sehr kurioses Spiel.
Voll, auf jeden Fall. Also klar, natürlich sieht man sowas hier und da. Ich würde aber sagen, dass es in dieser Drastik und in dieser Einseitigkeit und auch in der– also ich meine, gut, Kiel macht dann das Tor. Aber es ist ja noch nicht mehr so, dass man aus diesem Moment sagen würde, da muss Kiel jetzt ein Tor machen. Also Kehrta macht aus so vielen hochprozentigen Chancen exakt gar kein Tor und Kiel macht aus nichts eins. Und das finde ich wirklich– also ich konnte gar nicht glauben, was ich da sehe, weil ich irgendwie gedacht habe, es ist vielleicht irgendwie so ein Zusammenschnitt oder Deepfake oder ich weiß es nicht was, um irgendwie die Hertha Heim-Misere überspitzt noch mal auf einen Punkt zu bringen. Ein bisschen eben dazu, dass ich finde, dass in dieser Anwendung der Videobeweis, weiß ich nicht genau wie viel für den Sport tut, weil ich denn wirklich, also ohne Mist, ich hatte es dann ja auch in diese viel zitierte WhatsApp-Gruppe geschrieben, das kann halt nicht sein, dass Spieler mit großen Füßen einen Nachteil haben. Weil die Fußspitze darüber entscheidet, ob er im Abseits steht oder nicht, dann muss man halt die Regel dahingehend anpassen, dass an der Ferse gemessen wird. Also, wisst ihr, was ich meine? Das ist irgendwie…
Ist das nicht das, was Arsene Wenger machen möchte? Ist das nicht sein Vorschlag, dass die Linie nach hinten verschoben wird?
Also, irgendwie denke ich, dass… Also, ich… Ja, ich sehe den Punkt so. Ich verstehe die Idee des Videobeweises. Und das ist ja jetzt auch nicht der erste Anlass, der da irgendwie zu Diskussionen anregt. Ja, aber inwieweit das Spiel davon profitieren soll, muss mir irgendwie nochmal jemand erklären.
Vor allem, weil man ja auch irgendwie sagen muss, also ich finde, anders als bei einer Torerzielung an sich, wo du natürlich immer drüber diskutieren kannst, über ja eine gewisse Vorteilsverschaffung, in großen Anführungszeichen hier, finde ich das bei einem Elfmeter schon auch nochmal. Also klar sollte man abseits nicht daran liegen, ob es jetzt eine rote Karte ist oder ein Tor oder ein Elfmeter, aber ich fand es irgendwie einfach krass, in dem Moment dann zu sagen, ja, weil da dann der Innenverteidiger irgendwie mit rangeht und dies und das, ist das jetzt halt abseits. Deshalb gibt es den Anschließenden Elfmeter nicht. Ja, also ich hatte da auch irgendwie und also natürlich, sage ich auch direkt, ist es für die Schiedsrichter auf dem Platz auch absolut undankbar, weil sobald der VHR draufguckt, was willst du halt tun, kann ich halt auch irgendwie verstehen, dann wird halt hinterher auch wieder gesagt, ja wo haben wir das denn, aber ich denke mir halt auch so, also das ist ja auch wirklich was, das kann ja kein Linienrichter aus dem Laufen und Spiel bei einem Freistoß, wo da wirklich ja gefühlt 20 Mann auf einem Raum stehen, erkennen und also ich meine, ich sag jetzt mal in dem Sinne, für Hertha geht es halt sowieso nicht mehr um so wahnsinnig viel, aber und trotzdem muss man natürlich sagen, wenn es den Elfmeter braucht, um das Tor zu erzielen, kann man natürlich genauso drüber diskutieren, also es war jetzt nicht so, dass sie vorher, also dass sie drei Tore geschossen haben und ihnen wurde allen drei aberkannt. Also das muss man trotzdem auch noch sagen. Ich fand es auch schon wirklich einigermaßen kurios und das Hauptproblem, und das hatte Marc, glaube ich, auch geschrieben, dass du natürlich einmal mehr vor allem als Stadiongänger überhaupt nicht abgeholt wirst. Also und das ist, das bleibt mein Hauptkritikpunkt am VAR, diese mangelnde Transparenz, das ist für mich einfach nicht nachvollziehbar. Und Thorsten, du hast das eben schon einmal im Vorgespräch gesagt, vielleicht mit einer kleinen persönlichen Note, dass Kiel jetzt auch zum zweiten Mal eventuell auch von Schiedsrichterentscheidungen profitiert. Ich meine, man muss halt auch trotzdem sagen, und dass wir vielleicht trotzdem einmal noch positiv auf Kiel schauen, sie schaffen es aber trotzdem, dieses Tor aus dem Nichts zu erzielen. Und das ist ja im Abstiegskampf, ehrlich gesagt. Also du siehst, dass du eigentlich über weite Strecken dieses Spiel die unterlegene Mannschaft bist, über Chancenverwertung, was auch irgendwie kreative Offensivstärke betrifft, etc. bist. Und du schaffst es trotzdem, diesen einen Moment zu haben. Und Thorsten, das ist natürlich schon das, was eigentlich dieses Glück haben nicht viele im Abstiegskampf dann ja auch. Und das musst du dir ja auch erarbeiten. Wie siehst du das?
Ja, absolut. Und wir wollen ja auch z.B. letzte Woche das Spiel gegen Kaiserslautern nicht vergessen. Das 3 zu 0, das war doch sehr souverän von Holstein Kiel. Also es ist natürlich nicht alles Glück. Das wäre jetzt eine wirklich absolut falsche Darstellung. Ich wollte aber noch erwähnen, da sind wir noch nicht drauf eingegangen, dass Teggelson den Ball auch mit der Hand spielt vor dem 1 zu 0, noch einen kurzen Doppelpass, also einen gefühlten Doppelpass mit Haares hat und dann das Tor erzielt. Da kann man ehrlicherweise auch noch fragen, war das nicht Handspiel des Torschützen im Vorfeld der Torerzielung? Also wirklich unglückliche Schiedsrichterleistung und es war der einzige Torschuss von Kiel, der auf das Tor von Hertha kam. 9 zu 1 Chancen, es ist wirklich krass gewesen. Und in Düsseldorf, muss man sagen, hatten sie auch ein bisschen Schiedsrichterglück, aber es ist eine mega Floskel, aber das Glück des Tüchtigen, es kommt ja dann immer zusammen. Du hast halt dann ein, zwei Spiele, die für dich laufen und so war es eben jetzt bei Kiel. Und damit kommt auch ein gewisses Selbstverständnis, aber ganz ehrlich, zur Partie herrter Kiel, muss man sagen, in neun von zehn Fällen verliert Kiel diese Partie. Und es war wirklich das eine Freakspiel, wo es umgekehrt gelaufen ist. Ich glaube, das kann man bei aller Ferne des Gegenüber Kiel, kann man das schon sagen.
Ich finde das schon insgesamt wirklich bemerkenswert, dass wir– ich hatte es im Vorgespräch schon gesagt– dass wir, finde ich, an diesem Spieltag die Eintracht in Kaiserslautern, dann haben wir Magdeburg in Nürnberg, wir haben Kiel in Berlin bei der Hertha. Thorsten, du hattest vor Thuner Düsseldorf in dieser Reihe noch ergänzt Abstiegskandidaten, die– also vor allem Magdeburg, die wirklich für eine hohe Anzahl an Abschlüssen stehen, die gerne irgendwie mit dem Ball nach vorne gehen, sich irgendwie erst ab Minute 60 wieder auf ihre ursprüngliche Spielphilosophie besonnen haben. Und vielleicht ist das das Mittel der Wahl im Sprint, jetzt an diesen letzten Spieltagen, Fehler zu vermeiden, weil irgendwie mehr Ballbesitz zu mehr Fehlpässen führen kann, zu mehr Möglichkeiten für den Gegner, diese für sich zu nutzen. Und in Führung zu gehen, ich weiß es nicht genau, ich sehe nur, dass es an diesem Spieltag weird häufig geklappt hat, sogar bei Kiel. Und ich auch bei Kiel, wir werden ja später noch wahrscheinlich über Kaiserslautern gegen Eintracht Braunschweig sprechen. Das Gefühl hatte, dass da einfach auch Mindgames wirklich eine große Rolle spielen, weil sowohl Kaiserslautern als auch Hertha spielen in der Tabelle für oben oder unten keine Rolle mehr, haben aber zu Hause aus unterschiedlichen Gründen total Druck. Und wenn du den für dich spielen lassen kannst als Auswärtsteam, dann ist natürlich ganz smart. Das ist eine unüberprüfbare These, weil so gemein wird sich kein Trainer geben in der Pressekonferenz, dem Trainerkollegen, der natürlich immer geschätzt wird, und so weiter und so fort, das Publikum gegen sich aufbringen zu wollen. Ich kann mir aber vorstellen, vielleicht Tim Walter, dass er da so eine kleine Idee hatte. Aber ich weiß es natürlich nicht genau.
Eine kurze Ergänzung, Thorsten und Anna, bei Magneburg hat es natürlich aber nicht geklappt. Also die haben 0-1 gegen Nürnberg verloren. Für Nürnberg dann eben der Klassenerhalt gewesen. Also das nur zur Ergänzung. Aber jetzt darfst du natürlich auch, Thorsten.
Ja, und das wollte ich auch noch sagen mit Magneburg. Und auch, dass man ehrlicherweise, ich habe mit Thomas gestern tatsächlich kurz telefoniert, unserem Magneburg-Experten. Und er war halt auch nicht von dieser Herangehensweise überzeugt, die Magneburg-Nürnberg an den Tag gelegt hat. Denn ganz ehrlich, wenn man Magneburg diese Saison sieht, das ist nicht ihre Identität, das ist nicht ihr Spiel. Das passt nicht zu dieser Mannschaft, wenn man sich auch die Ballbesitzverhältnisse in der Liga anguckt. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das zielführend für Magneburg ist. Ich wollte aber zu Kiel noch sagen, wenn man das Restprogramm sich anguckt, dann ist Kiel wirklich jetzt noch nicht nur das Zünglein an der Waage, sie sind ja auch noch selbstgefährdet. Sie spielen jetzt zu Hause gegen euch, gegen Braunschweig, dann nochmal zu Hause gegen Magneburg und auswärts in Dresden.
Das wusste ich gar nicht. Ich dachte, ihr seid die mit dem schlimmen Programm.
Das wird interessant. Sie sind komplett in direkten Duellen noch, was natürlich auch dazu führen kann, wenn Kiel wiederum schwächelt, dass sie dann doch noch wieder runterrutschen könnten. Ich sehe sie zumindest noch nicht ganz durch, trotz des aktuellen, wirklich guten Formverlaufs.
Zumal du, finde ich, nicht davon ausgehen kannst, dass du das, was du jetzt da gegen die Hertha gemacht hast, gegen die anderen Vereine auch machen kannst. Ja, die Nettwurfs nicht. Ja, je nachdem, wie es da dann bei denen aussieht. Und Paderborn kann ich total verstehen. Also gerade gegen Nürnberg, glaube ich, hättest du da gute Karten gehabt, mit deiner selbstbewussten Art und Weise einfach einen Auswärtssieg mitzunehmen.
Aber ja, und vor allem, wir haben ja Kiel gegen Münster gesehen, ne? Also das war ja auch schon dieses 0-0. Das sollten sie sich natürlich gegen die beiden, also für Kiel wird es dann wahrscheinlich am Ende reichen. Ich würde ihnen aber trotzdem einfach mal nicht empfehlen, da in diesen Partien auf die Unentschieden zu gehen. Aber das ist natürlich auch, also beispielsweise für Thorsten und meinen Verein per se eine gute Nachricht und ja für Braunschweig nach diesem 32.Spieltag auch, dass wir eben noch Vereine haben, die sich da unten gegenseitig potenziell Punkte wegnehmen können. Weil dann, also es gibt halt nur zwei Direkte und einen Relegationsplatz, der zum Abstieg führen könnte. Das ist dann natürlich für die restlichen Vereine und dann, ja, ob es eine gute Nachricht ist. Also dann heißt es halt irgendwann, dass wenn du deine Spiele gut gestaltest, vielleicht so ein bisschen entspannter auf die restlichen Plätze gucken kannst. Genau. Dann haben wir noch eine Partie. Dann haben wir auch Lage der Liga, auch irgendwie mal gefühlt bei einer Stunde mal abgefrüstückt. Denn wir hatten ja ein Samstagabend-Duell zwischen Darmstadt und Elversberg. Und ich will mal sagen, also das hat gut unterhalten. Darmstadt mit Doppelschlag durch Pfeiffer und Hornby in der 14. und 15. Minute. Zimmerschied in der 26. und Rohr in der 34. können dann ausgleichen für Elversberg. Pfeiffer sieht rot, nach Faul an Mock war kurz vor der Pause. Und Petkov zum 3 zu 2 in der zweiten Minute der Nachspielzeit. Also wir hatten schon mal gut entspannt fünf Tore in den ersten 45 Minuten. Und kurz nach Wiederbeginn, da erzählt Hornby dann das 3-3. Und man muss sagen, Darmstadt macht das, trotz Unterzahl, extrem gut. Ich finde, man konnte da wieder das Darmstadt durchblicken sehen, was so in den letzten Wochen vielleicht ab und zu mal gefehlt hat. Und dann gab es hinterher noch Diskussionen, warum Lukas Pink hat eigentlich nicht, auch in der 85. Minute mit rot vom Platz muss, nach Faul an Liebberg. Sprechen wir vielleicht gleich auch. Aber erstmal an euch beide. Die Frage, Thorsten, ich fange kurz bei dir an. Wie hat dir denn die Partie generell gefallen?
Ja, hat auf jeden Fall einen großen Unterhaltungswert. Und Darmstadt geht in Führung durch eine ihrer großen Stärken, nämlich die Eckbälle und die Standards. Und das ist natürlich kein Nachteil, wenn Elversberg dann kommen muss. Und man sieht, wie gefestigt Elversberg auch aktuell ist. Hat das Spiel dann komplett, ja, sich mehr oder weniger gezogen. Und ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob es Matthias war oder sonst, wer in der Rasenfunkgruppe einhatte, geschrieben. Und das fand ich sehr treffend, dass Darmstadt gefühlt in Unterzahl sogar fast besser gespielt hat in der zweiten Halbzeit, als in der ersten, als Eversberg dann aufkam. Also da muss man auch sagen, ein großer Respekt vor Darmstadt. Und ja, trotz allem steht so ein bisschen die Befürchtung im Raum, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht ganz gereicht hat am Ende dieser Punkt, weil eben Darmstadt in den letzten Wochen, gerade auswärts zum Beispiel in Bielefeld ja, doch ein bisschen sehr geschwächelt hat. Und ich finde, man merkt, man merkt es teilweise den Trainern an, dass sie– also, welche Vereine gefühlt da unter Druck stehen und welche Vereine das Thema Aufstieg mehr so als optional ansehen. Ja, es kann, aber es muss nicht. Und ich finde, bei Florian Kohfeldt merkt man das hier und da. Der ist grundsätzlich doch sehr emotional bei den Spielen selber, hinterher dann meistens gefasster. Vincent Wagner auch zumindest kommt mir auf jeden Fall als sehr schlechter Verlierer rüber in den meisten Partien, wenn er mal ein Spiel verloren hat. Aber ich finde, das ist zum Beispiel ein Unterschied zu Paderborn, wo ich gefühlt schon eine größere Gelassenheit bei Kettemann sehe. Und ich glaube, man kann natürlich als Darmstadt jetzt nicht sich automatisch zu den Aufstiegskandidaten zählen. Hat vermutlich auch gerade in der Hinserie ein bisschen overperformed. Und das sind dann so ein bisschen die Geister, die man rief. Man hat jetzt eigentlich diesen Willen, das zu schaffen. Und die Ernüchterung ist natürlich jetzt groß, dass man knapp scheitert, insbesondere, weil das natürlich als Zweitligist immer bedeutet, ja, in dieser Klasse kommen wir wahrscheinlich nicht mehr zusammen mit Blick auf das Sturmduo. Es hat sich ja Hornby sogar auch verletzt und fällt die letzten Spiele aus. Man munkelt schon, könnte sein letztes Spiel für Darmstadt gewesen sein. Also so schön und unterhaltsam, um den Burgen wieder zu deiner Frage zu schließen. So schön und unterhaltsam das Spiel war. So bitter wahrscheinlich die Erkenntnis, trotz wirklich absolut ehrenwerter Leistung in Unterzahl, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht gereicht hat am Ende oder reichen wird für Darmstadt.
Ja, Anna, ich hatte nämlich auch das Gefühl, gerade nach dem 2.0 wirkte Darmstadt für mich fast kurz ein bisschen selbst erschrocken. So und da hatte ich eben dann kurz auch das Gefühl, da war wieder dies, oh, wir können jetzt wieder was verlieren da. Also weil man war dann eben gerade mit diesen möglichen zusätzlichen drei Punkten, war man eben dieser Aufstiegsriege wieder so ein bisschen näher gekommen. Man muss ja jetzt, also natürlich rechnerisch ist noch nichts durch und man spielt ja auch noch direkt gegen Paderborn am letzten Spieltag. Da gibt es eben noch dieses direkte Duell. Spielt jetzt gegen Karlsruhe, dann gegen Münster. Aber man muss ja ehrlichweise mal sagen, 5 Punkte Rückstand auf Elversberg, 6 auf Hannover, 7 auf Paderborn. Wie realistisch siehst du denn noch bei Darmstadt, dass sie da noch zumindest in den Religationsplatz erklimmen können?
Das sehe ich nicht mehr, weil sie einfach von diesen Mannschaften da oben zu wackelmütig, oder am wackelmütigsten sind. Hannover hat sich ja so ein bisschen aus dem, ich finde, Hannover und Darmstadt haben so ein bisschen Tendenz und Plätze getauscht, von Runde zu Rückrunde. Hannover ja mit einer sehr guten, stabilen Rückrunde, mit so einem kleinen Low vielleicht, aber haben sich jetzt gerade irgendwie über ihre Top-Spiele, die sie ja nicht verloren haben im Gegensatz zur Rückrunde, da so ganz gut rangewandt, im Gegensatz eben zu Darmstadt, die da am entscheidenden Punkt zu viel Boden verloren haben. Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass sie den wieder einholen werden. Zum einen wegen der Ausfälle und zum anderen, das ist jetzt so eine kleine Prognose, habe ich bei beiden Mannschaften das Gefühl, irgendwie will man es zu sehr. Also das, was ich bei Elversberg über lange Strecken, was mir sehr imponiert hat, diese Spritzigkeit und Aggressivität, finde ich, ist so ein bisschen gemündet in eine gewisse, Kopflosigkeit ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel gesagt, aber sie spielen doch, finde ich, gerade offensiv ungenauer, als sie das über weite Teile der Saison getan haben. Und diese Dynamik, die du gerade, nach der du gefragt hast, Eva, kann man jetzt wieder was verlieren, finde ich, hat man irgendwie bei beiden Teams im gleichen Spiel zu unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten gemerkt. Also bei Darmstadt nach der Führung zu Hause, oh, okay, es geht einen Raum durch, die Stimmung ist gut, jetzt können wir ihn nur enttäuschen. Und Eversberg dann mit diesem Erfolgstruck dann in Überzahl über die zweite Halbzeit hinweg und so richtig souverän. Das Spiel war super, sehr unterhaltsam. Und groteskerweise ja mit einem sehr ähnlichen Verlauf zu dem Schalke-Spiel oder das Schalke-Spiel sehr ähnlich mit dem Verlauf zu dem Spiel in Darmstadt. Aber ich finde, gerade im Vergleich der Top-Spiele, Paderborn, Schalke und Darmstadt, Eversberg, siehst du schon die Lücke zwischen diesen Favoriten, weil ich Paderborn stärker finde als Darmstadt. Und im Moment auch Eversberg. Über die lange Zeit vielleicht nicht, aber im Moment finde ich Eversberg irgendwie ist da, weiß ich nicht, hat es geknackst, ist mein Eindruck.
Ja, Eversberg jetzt eben auch mit dem direkten Duell gegen Paderborn am Wochenende in Düsseldorf, dann Münster. Also wir haben tatsächlich bei einigen Vereinen, dass jetzt noch sie spielen entweder gegen die direkte Konkurrenz oder eben gegen Mannschaften aus dem unteren Tabellendrittel, um die ist halt auch noch für die ist halt wahrscheinlich, höchstwahrscheinlich gut bei Münster. Werden wir gleich vielleicht noch mit einem sozusagen, könnte es da sowieso schon vorbei sein. Aber ich glaube, weil wir jetzt Paderborn immer schon angeklungen haben, würde ich tatsächlich vorschlagen, wir springen jetzt auch zum SCP und damit zum ersten Verein. Gewohnter Rasenfunk-Vanier, La Liga ist etwas eskaliert, aber ich glaube, das beschreibt es auch gerade ganz gut. Wir schauen auf den SCP Paderborn. Es ist Platz 2, es sind 58 Punkte, es sind 54 zu 38 Tore, 17 Siege, 7 Unentschieden und 7 Niederlagen. In der Formtabelle in den letzten 5 Spielen ist man auf Platz 4, mit 3 Siegen und einem Unentschieden an der Niederlage. Generell ist diese 2 zu 3 Niederlage gegen Schalke am Wochenende die erste seit dem 20. Spieltag gegen na, Fortuna Düsseldorf Anfang Februar. Dafür ist es eben eine sehr bittere, also auch hier gab es eine 2-0-Führung. Durch die Heimannschaft, durch Cura und Marino in der 13. und 26. Minute Schalke stellt aber vor der Pause mit Lubicic und Auschisch auf 2-2, Lubicic dann auch der Match-Winner in der 83. Minute. Das nur zu dem Spielverlauf am Wochenende. Ich glaube generell ist ja diese Niederlage überhaupt nicht schlimm. Also ganz isoliert betrachtet kannst du natürlich gegen Schalke 04 verlieren. Allerdings ist natürlich mit dem Sieg der Hannoverader in Karlsruhe und eben, dass Elbersberg zumindest nicht verloren hat gegen Darmstadt, ist einfach ungünstig, weil man eben den Abstand auf die Vereine unterein nicht aufbauen konnte und natürlich einfach der Abstand zu Schalke, der ist natürlich durch diese drei Punkte, die dann weg sind, gestiegen. Anna, ich fange mal kurz bei dir an. Beim SCP, finde ich, es gab eigentlich viel zu sehen, was Paderborn eigentlich die ganze Saison schon stark macht. Also diese Effizienz, diese Kontastärke. Also es war ja eigentlich SCP-Fußball par excellence. Wo war denn, also ist immer so eine gemeine Frage, aber lag es für dich am Ende mehr an der Stärke von Schalke, dass Paderborn dieses Spiel am Ende verliert? Oder sagst du, vielleicht gab es da auch einfach, na taktisch gesehen oder so, einfach das, was Paderborn vielleicht noch fehlt, um wirklich die Spitzen-Spitzen-Spitzen-Spitzen-Mannschaft der 2. Liga zu sein?
Ich glaube, das ist eine trügerische Kombination aus beidem. Weil ich glaube, dass Schalke zu diesem Zeitpunkt der Saison und mit diesem frischen Elbersberg-Erfolg in Unverdienter Unterzahl das Spiel auswärts trotzdem zu gewinnen, sich das einfach nicht nehmen lassen möchte. Und ich finde, ich weiß, wir wollen über Paderborn sprechen. Es ist super schwer, finde ich. Weil im Kontext dieses Spiels kein Weg dran vorbei führt, zu sagen, wow, Schalke, das ist einfach richtig übel, da nicht einzubrechen, wenn du auswärts verhältnismäßig hoch in Rückstand gerätst. Dann hatte in den Stimmen nach dem Spiel der Trainer auch zu Recht darauf hingewiesen, dass in dem Moment, in dem Paderborn geführt hat, sie ja auch Tabellenführer waren. Also dieser mentale Moment von, jetzt geben wir auch noch die Tabellenführung ab, an den Gegner gehen, den wir gerade spielen. Und ich glaube, Schalke hat das einfach verweigert. Und was da dann genau passiert, schwer zu sagen, ich würde eher sagen, es liegt an Schalke. Weil Paderborn dafür eigentlich zu smart spielt, um sich sowas noch irgendwie aus der Hand geben zu lassen. Und ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass sie sich nach der einzigen Delle in der Hinrunde, was nämlich genau jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt der Saison war, sie haben gegen Hannover verloren, sie haben gegen Schalke verloren und gegen Elbersberg verloren. Und jetzt haben sie gegen Hannover Unentschieden geholt, dass sie sich vorgenommen haben, dass das nicht passiert. Natürlich, klar, wir wollen ja aufsteigen. Und ich glaube, all in all, es liegt mehr an Schalke als an Paderborn, dass das noch in die Binsen ging, aus Paderborner Sicht.
Sie haben auf jeden Fall hinten raus auch ein bisschen tatsächlich die Power verloren. Vielleicht haben sie ein bisschen overpaced in der ersten Halbzeit. Da fand ich sie bei den Kontern– also generell das Tempo der ersten Halbzeit– war echt hoch. Und das Spiel ist deutlich ruhiger geworden in der zweiten Hälfte. Und dann war es, wie du gesagt hast, Schalkes Wucht ist momentan– die mentale Stärke von Schalke ist kaum zu bremsen. Und so war es auch in der Partie. Man hat das so ein bisschen abgeschüttelt und dann ging es los. Und ich glaube, das war dann so eine Mischung aus diesem Druck, den Schalke entfacht hat. Wo Schalke auch nochmal nachlegen konnte, auch energetisch. Und dass man selber aber– ich will nicht sagen, dass Pulver verschossen hatte in der ersten Halbzeit, aber zumindest sehr viel Energie schon gelassen hat.
Ja, Thorsten, ich nehme mal so ein bisschen was auf, was Anna nämlich gerade gesagt hat. Nämlich, dass man ja in der Hinrunde diese Däler hatte. Und zwar ja gegen Mitkonkurrenten im Ausstiegskampf. Und jetzt ist es eben wieder so, man konnte in der ganzen Saison zumindest gegen diesen oberen Rieger, konnte man eben nicht gewinnen. Und da muss man ja sagen, für Paderborn keine wahnsinnig gute Nachricht jetzt im Endspurt. Also das muss man ja trotzdem sagen, weil wir haben es eben schon gesagt, als erstes jetzt eben, als nächstes Elversberg. Dann kommt Karlsruhe. Okay, auch die haben, also ich habe es glaube ich in der letzten Folge schon gesagt, es gibt dann so ein paar Vereine, für die mag es in der Saison nicht mehr um so viel gehen. Aber die haben noch richtig ordentlich oben und unten ihre Finger im Spiel. Karlsruhe ist es jetzt dabei. Dann ist es eben Hertha und Kaiserslautern. Und dann geht es am letzten Spieltag gegen Darmstadt. Und ja, gut, okay, Darmstadt will dann vielleicht, je nachdem wie die nächsten Partien laufen, vielleicht letzte Hoffnung auf dem Redegationsplatz, aber vielleicht auch einfach erfolgreiches Ende der Saison. Da ist dann schon die Frage, ist es dann vielleicht doch, diese, ja, wir haben eben gesagt, mentale Stärke, die Schalke hat, ist das vielleicht so der letzte Punkt, wirklich der bei Paderborn irgendwie fehlt, um es ganz kalt schnurrt sich jetzt zum Ende zu bringen?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Und ich glaube, es gibt auch eine gute Antwort. Wenn man sich die Paderborner Mannschaft anguckt, dann muss man einfach feststellen, viele Spieler sind einfach sehr, sehr jung. Paderborn hat eigentlich nicht so die abgezockten 2. Liga-Hasen, auf wenige Ausnahmen. Also klar, da ist Felix Götze hinten. Und natürlich hat man vorne, auch wenn er jetzt nicht zwingend Stammspieler ist, mit Sven Nicheln, einen sehr erfahrenen Mann. Aber wenn wir uns andere Spieler angucken, also selbst der aktuelle Shooting-Star Laurin Kurda ist immer noch sehr, sehr jung. Das beginnt bei seinem im Tor. Jetzt Ruben Müller in der Defensive macht es wirklich hervorragend. Aber er ist auch 20 Jahre jung, etc. Und ich glaube, das ist am Ende, gerade wenn es hart auf hart kommt, das zeigt ja doch die Erfahrung von der ein oder anderen 2. Liga oder auch 1. Liga-Saison, die man so erlebt hat. Am Ende ist Erfahrung in solchen letzten Spielen, dass der Kopf klar ist, das ist wichtig. Und ich befürchte, da muss Paderborn als Mannschaft einfach noch so ein bisschen lernen. Ansonsten bin ich aber echt großer Fan. Also gerade von der Kaderbreite. Ich finde nämlich, es gibt kein großes Leistungsgefälle in Paderborner Kader. Das sieht man beispielsweise in der Offensive. Offensive, mein Gott. Biblia hat 14 Tore erzielt. Das ist natürlich schon ein absoluter Top-Wert. Aber daneben variieren die Spieler. Zurzeit spielt vor allem Stefano Marino. Davor war Stefan Tigges so ein bisschen der Mann. Im Winter kam Kennedy Ocpalla aus Mannheim. Alle haben so ihre Spielzeit gehabt und gefühlt hat das Offensivspiel grundsätzlich funktioniert. Außer Biblia hat keiner jetzt so eine richtig krasse Quote da vorne. Aber das spricht einfach für eine zumindest gute Kaderbreite. Und dass das System von Ralf Kettemann auch auf diese Mannschaft, sagen wir mal, ein bisschen unabhängig vom Personal anwendbar ist. Man darf das nicht unerwähnt lassen. Jetzt ist natürlich mit Obermeier der Kapitän auch weggebrochen. Achilles sehen anderes. Die Saison ist gelaufen. Das ist natürlich ein wichtiger Spieler auf der Außenbahn gewesen. Das ist natürlich auch einer der erfahreneren, der vielleicht auch gerade in dieser Partie dann wichtig gewesen wäre. Das ist natürlich dann auch keine gute Nachricht für die anderen Spieler. Aber ich glaube, es ist so diese Mischung aus Unerfahrenheit und dann dadurch bedingter, fehlender mentaler Stärke in diesen entscheidenden Spielen.
Anna, du wolltest auch noch etwas ergänzen.
Ich glaube, nicht zu unterschätzender Vorteil, an dem sich wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen, vor allem die internen Geister scheiden, ist, und das finde ich total cool, dass Paderborn oder das Paderborner Spieler seit einigen Wochen sagen, wir wollen aufsteigen und wir werden aufsteigen. Und damit riskierst du natürlich ein bisschen was. Du machst dich angreifbar. Du musst dich daran messen lassen, dass du das ausrufst. Aber ich finde das gerade als neutraler Zuschauer so angenehm, weil natürlich wollen wir aufsteigen. Also wirklich jeder, also auch Darmstadt denkt das noch und rechnet das durch, unter welchen Bedingungen das möglich wäre. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das nach außen zu tragen hat, natürlich so eine gewisse Prolligkeit, die ich finde, aber einer so jungen Mannschaft, wie Thorsten es gerade beschrieben hat, der man das irgendwie auch leichter zugesteht als vielleicht so erfahrenen Spielern oder so ein bisschen seniorigeren Mannschaft. Ich finde das total cool und ich kann mir wirklich vorstellen, dass das, also einfach dieses Manifestieren, dass das wirklich einen Unterschied machen wird in diesem Endspurt und in diesem Rumgeeier, wir wollen das Maximum rausholen, wir wollen gucken, was geht und so weiter und so fort. Weil ich glaube, dass du einfach jetzt, wenn du aufsteigen möchtest, umschalten musst. Und zwar eben auch in dieser öffentlichen Haltung.
Als Anhänger eines Vereins, der genau das vor der Saison groß ausgerufen hat, kann ich nur davon warnen, ob es offensiv seine Ziele zu vollständigen.
Also das tatsächlich ist da auch wirklich ausgenommen. Ich meine, wenn du einfach jetzt, du bist Zweiter, was sollen die denn sagen?
Nee, das ist richtig.
So, wenn die im Interview stehen, nach diesem Heimspiel 2-0 irgendwie gegen Schalke geführt und die werden gefragt, ja und so, wie geht es ihnen? Was machen sie jetzt? Dann sagen sie, na ja, wir wollen jetzt aufsteigen. So, wir sind Zweiter, was willst du denn von mir? Und das finde ich total, also natürlich. Und das finde ich irgendwie cool, dass die das riskieren, sehe aber natürlich auch den Grund und alles, warum man das nicht macht. Weil man dann eben drauf festgenagelt wird, wenn es nicht funktioniert und darauf keinen Bock hat. Auffällig legitim.
Das ist sehr interessant, vor allem drei F-Kette. Man hat nach dem Spiel gesagt, ja, also im Idealfall war das halt ein Vorgeschmack auf die Bundesliga, was man halt nicht machen darf. Und zwar, wir müssen uns jetzt schon darauf einstellen. Das fand ich tatsächlich sehr, sehr interessant, weil auch das hörst du sehr wenig, dass ein Trainer eben dann schon Ausblick darauf gibt, welche Fehler du in der Bundesliga nicht machen darfst. Und er hat eben ganz klar gesagt, ja, in der Bundesliga werden halt genau solche Momente bestraft. Und das haben wir heute gesehen. Ist natürlich gleichzeitig auch ein riesiges Kompliment an Schalke 04, wo wir natürlich wirklich nochmal sagen müssen, also so ruckelig, wie die Systemumstellung begann zum rückrunden Start. Das so überzeugt, dass es jetzt, sie haben jetzt im zweiten Spiel in Folge auch mal mehr Tore erzielt. Auch das hatten wir über viele Strecken der Saison nicht. Aber ja, das fand ich auch sehr interessant. Generell haben wir mit Schalke und Paderborn die beiden Vereine, die die wenigsten Spiele nach Führung verloren haben, respektive der Anzahl an Führungen. Also Paderborn hat nach Führung erst drei Spiele verloren. Das ist bei 23 Führungen schon eindrucksvoll. Davon hat man 17 gewonnen. Also diese Überzeugung ist ja per se auch schon da. Schalke hat halt den Bestwert. Ich glaube, die haben keine einzige oder eine Partie nur verloren nach Führung. Das ist natürlich ja auch durchaus… Also du hast dann an Paderborn-Stelle leider wirklich so ein bisschen den Gegner gehabt, der dann halt wirklich auch da erstmal nicht untersteckt. Und das ist dann natürlich ein bisschen schwierig. Generell kann ich sagen, es gibt… Also weil das so ein bisschen zu dem passt, Thorsten, was du auch, glaube ich, angesprochen hast, von dieser Breite des Kaders und sowas. Und zwar war Ralf Kettemann im From Coach to Coach-Podcast und erzählt so ein bisschen, dass er eben ganz viel, eigentlich 11 gegen 11 trainieren lässt. Also es gibt ja die Trainer, die so ein bisschen detaillierter auf das 2 gegen 2, 2 gegen 3, minimale Überzahl etc. gehen und sehr in das Klein-Klein quasi reingehen. Und dann, er halt eben sagt, ne, er guckt eben eher aufs große Ganze, weil das ist am Ende eben auch das, was im Spiel gespielt wird. Und ich glaube, das passt auch ganz gut. Du hast halt einfach gemerkt, also eine Mannschaft konnte irgendwie nochmal mit ihren individueller Klasse ganz gut umstellen in der Partie. Und Paderborn kommt da halt auch einfach in ihre Grenzen. Aber das ist natürlich, und ich glaube, das sind wir uns alle einig, mehr kann auf hohem Niveau. Das einzige Problem, was man, also sie hatten glaube ich dann Glück, dass Schalke das irgendwie nicht noch höher gewinnt. Weil, ich weiß, ich wiederhole mich da, aber Tordifferenz wird noch wahnsinnig wichtig werden. Weil die ist einfach, also da hat sich jetzt von vor zwei Wochen nicht wahnsinnig viel getan. Das ist alles brutal nahe aneinander. Also Schalke und Elbersberg jeweils mit einer positiven Differenz von 20. Paderborn und Hannover 16, der Amstatt, also in Anführungszeichen 15. Das kann noch entscheidend werden. Und das ist glaube ich deshalb, bin ich da auch gespannt, wie wir jetzt mit Elbersberg und Paderborn zwei Mannschaften, die sich glaube ich beide in der Defensive so ein bisschen formieren müssen, jetzt für diese Partie, die aber eigentlich auch beide wissen, naja, ein 1-1 hilft vielleicht in der Gesamtkonstellation Paderborn ein bisschen mehr weiter. Aber wenn du dich in die bestmöglichste Position bringen willst für die letzten beiden Spiele, musst du diese Partie gewinnen. Und das finde ich als neutrale Zuschauerin sehr spannend, weil ich hasse ehrlich gesagt wirklich nichts mehr an diesen letzten beiden Spieltagen, bevor der letzte Spieltag dann wirklich alles parallel läuft. Dieses, ach ja, die Mannschaft hat ja so und so gespielt und dann reicht uns vielleicht das. Ich weiß, ich plädiere da seit Jahren für, aber ich bin eigentlich der Meinung, Minimum die letzten beiden Spieltage alle gleiche Uhrzeit, weil das für mich die Sache immer noch ein bisschen spannender macht. Also, ja. Gut, also wie gesagt, leichte Empfehlung für diesen Podcast. Ich finde manche Aussagen wie, in Barcelona geht es wirklich nur um Fußball. Da ist nichts mit Chikimiki. Fand ich jetzt ein bisschen verstörend. Ehrlich gesagt. Aber sonst wäre einfach so ein bisschen was über, also meiner Meinung nach hört bei den privaten Teil vielleicht so ein bisschen weg. Das finde ich etwas anstrengend zuzuhören. Aber sonst habe ich euch die Folge verlinkt. Per se finde ich es ja schon immer schön, wenn Trainer auch mal über ihre Sachen sprechen. Und weil das ja, wie ich finde, meistens so ein bisschen interessanter ist, gerade als dann immer auf die einzelnen Spieler zu gucken. Gut, wie gesagt, ich habe schon gesagt, die nächsten Spieler sind dann Elbersberg, Karlsruhe und Darmstadt. Und jetzt springen wir, falls ihr nichts mehr zum SCP zu sagen habt, das sieht nicht danach aus, paar Plätze weiter runter. Auch wirklich nur ein paar. Auf Platz 10. Da steht der Fahrerfeld Bochum mit 39 Punkten, 45 zu 44 Tore, 10 Siege, 9 Unentschieden und 12 Niederlagen. In der Formtabelle steht man so ein bisschen im Niemandsland auf Platz 12. Kommen wir vielleicht auch gleich mal was dazu. Warum ist denn für den VfL noch so ein bisschen spannend, wenn sagen, wer denn könnte, meine Güte, zwei Siege, drei Niederlagen? Nach der 0 zu 2 Niederlage gegen Dresden, jetzt sehr wichtige drei Punkte gegen die Spielvereinigung, führt am Wochenende, gab es ein 2 zu 1 Sieg. Thorsten, ich würde mal bei dir starten. Ich würde sagen, es ist kein Hot Take, aber ein fitter Philipp Hofmann ist das, was für den VfL Bochum dafür sorgen könnte, dass man eben dann in der Liga bleibt. Würdest du mir dabei zustimmen?
Kaum suggestiv die Frage, liebe Eva.
Nee, null.
Ja, ich glaube, da hast du was Richtiges gesagt. Ja, und generell halte ich das nicht für verkehrt, als Mannschaft unten im Abstiegskampf einen Torjäger zu haben, der verlässlich Tore erzielt. Philipp Hofmann ist zumindest jetzt mal in der 2. Saisonhälfte wieder zu dem geworden, der er einst für den VfL Bochum ja auch teilweise sogar in der Bundesliga war. Ja, das war seine Partie. Die hat er mit entschieden. Er hätte sogar noch ein 3 zu 0 erzielt, aber das wurde dann wegen einer Abseitsposition vorher abgepfiffen. Aber der VfL musste schon noch ein bisschen zittern hinten raus. Fürth war lange Zeit überraschend passiv, muss man sagen. Ja, auch wenn man bedenkt, dass sie letzte Woche ja gegen Darmstadt gewonnen hatten. Und normalerweise geht man davon aus, dass solche Partien ja auch ein bisschen beflügeln können. Und es war ja klar, dass das Spiel in Bochum ein sehr wichtiges sein würde. Aber lange Zeit sah es doch sehr enttäuschend aus. Also gefühlt sind sie erst so die letzten 20 Minuten so richtig aufgewacht. Dann aber so richtig. Und wenn man sich vor allem den Ballbesitzer anguckt, der 75%-Ballbesitz, dann bei Fürth am Ende leider eben nicht so viel aus Fürther Sicht dabei rumgekommen. Und ich glaube, das liegt natürlich zum einen daran, dass Bochum gerade zu Hause einfach sehr stark ist. Das Gegenteil ist tatsächlich der Fall auswärts. Schlechtes ist das Auswärtsteam. Das, glaube ich, spielt jetzt diese Saison vermutlich nicht mehr so eine richtige Rolle. Aber Bochum hat noch zwei Auswärtsspiele in den letzten Spielen. Das ist aber punktemäßig wahrscheinlich schon halbwegs safe. Halbwegs, denn in dieser 2. Liga weiß man das nie. Für mich, ganz interessant ist zu sehen, auf jeden Fall, Uwe Rösler hat es ja phasenweise wirklich geschafft, diese Mannschaft auch in einen guten Lauf reinzubringen. Der ist so ein bisschen vorbei bei Bochum, ganz klar. Ich glaube, da rumortet es auch durchaus ein bisschen. Man ist aktuell wahrscheinlich ähnlich wie viele Vereine, vor allem froh, wenn die Saison vorbei ist. Und man dann weiter schauen kann, wie es nächstes Jahr weitergeht. Am Ende war der Sieg schon verdient, weil Fürth einfach zu spät aufgewacht ist und Bochum bis zur 60. dann doch das dominante Team war. Aber ja, also ich würde sagen, von der Siegesserie abgesehen, davor vor allem und aber auch jetzt danach, ist Bochum diese Saison selten wirklich überzeugend. Ich finde, das muss man fairerweise auch sagen.
Anna, ich fand es so ein bisschen, die Partie war fast ja, so ein bisschen Beschreiben für die Bochumer Saison, jetzt vielleicht nicht genau von der, also vom Ablauf her, aber du triffst früh auch wie gegen Schalke und dann bist du aber, kommst selber auch in so eine komische Passivität und lädst, führt ein, also ich glaube, Furtkau ja auch mit zwei Chancen, kannst dann eben in der zweiten Halbzeit, also da kommt dann diese Griffigkeit zurück und dann wieder in der letzten Viertelstunde, führt irgendwie komplett unnötig, wieder einzeln an, Thorsten hat es ja skizziert. Findest du, das ist vor allem zu erklären am, am Kader oder siehst du da auch Uwe Rösler in der Pflicht?
Ich werde aus Bochum nicht so richtig schlau und das irgendwie vorweggenommen. Ich sehe Uwe Rösler da insofern in der Pflicht, als dass ich, dass ich das Spiel zu sehr gebunden sehe und damit auch den Erfolg an die Performance und Tagesform von konkreten Spielern. Also beispielsweise Philipp Hofmann in dem Spiel gegen uns war es auch ein fantastischer Gerrit Holtmann und das ist jetzt ja auch nicht schockierend oder nicht irgendwie total daneben, weil man weiß, ich habe einen grundsätzlich ganz guten Kader, der individuell im 1 gegen 1 mindestens bestehen kann, vielleicht sogar besser ist als der Gegner auf den entgegengestellten Positionen. Das, was ich vom VfL bisher gesehen habe, ist, dass sich ein bisschen sehr darauf verlassen wird, dass diese 1 gegen 1 Situation durch die individuelle Qualität von den Spielern dann aufgelöst werden und für den VfL entschieden werden, weil ich es jetzt spielerisch, ehrlich gesagt, nicht bestechend finde. Also ich finde, der Spielaufbau ist oft eher chaotisch, sagen wir so. Und dann hat Münde dieser Spielaufbau einfach relativ zuverlässig an einem Spieler, der ihn dann beruhigt und in die richtigen Bahnen lenkt. Die Frage, die sich da für mich anschließt, ist, was wird aus dem VfL Bochum, wenn diese großen, weiß ich nicht, ob es große Namen sind, aber diese Schlüsselspieler dann im Sommer bleiben sie oder gehen sie. Jetzt muss ich hier einmal diesen Namen nachschlagen des Leihspielers aus Leverkusen, Uni Jägera. Genau. Da sehe ich im Moment eine zu große Abhängigkeit, dass der Erfolg des VfL zu sehr abhängig ist von der individuellen Performance der Spieler, weil wenn sie nicht performen, da irgendwie wenig Konzept oder wenig Trainerpuffer hinter zu stehen scheint, auf denen dann das Gesamtkollektiv zurückgreifen kann.
Ja, vielleicht dazu kurz ergänzend. Ich habe ja Uwe Rösler anderthalb Jahre in Düsseldorf erleben dürfen als Trainer. Und natürlich gibt es so die Außendarstellung. Und ich glaube, wir haben vor ein paar Sendungen auch schon mal darüber gesprochen, inwiefern das sinnvoll ist oder nicht. Aber wenn man sich seinen Fußball anguckt, sehr pressingintensiv etc., aber tatsächlich wenig ballorientiert. Und ich glaube, das ist ein Problem, was man auch diese Saison bei Bochum sieht, dass sie sich mit dem Ball mitunter schwer tun. Das ist gerade nämlich schon gesagt. Spielaufbau wirkt manchmal etwas chaotisch und nicht so zielführend. Man sieht zumindest auch in der Ballbesitzstatistik Bochum ist das Team mit dem wenigsten Ballbesitz in der gesamten Liga. Das verwundert dann eigentlich, dass man in Heimspielen dann trotzdem so erfolgreich ist, weil man ja davon eigentlich ausgeht, dass man gerade in den Heimspielen da ein bisschen was machen können. Aber das ist eine Schwäche, die auch bei Uwe Rösler nach dem Abstieg in Düsseldorf in die 2. Liga ein bisschen zum Tragen kam. Denn tatsächlich haben wir beim Bundesliga-Abstieg häufig durchaus überzeugend gespielt. Natürlich aus dieser Rolle des Abstiegskandidaten mit viel Umschalten, Pressen etc. Aber in der 2. Liga hat das gar nicht mehr so gut funktioniert. Klar, Kader hatte auch einen großen Umbruch. Aber eben, da war eben das Problem. Jetzt bist du der Absteiger, bist vor Thuner Düsseldorf. Du musst mit dem Ball was zeigen, vor allem in deinen Heimspielen. Und das hat häufig nicht so funktioniert. Das ist eine Schwäche bei Uwe Rösler. Und ich glaube deshalb, das passt auch so ganz gut zu deinen Beobachtungen. Das wollte ich dazu noch sagen, bevor wir vielleicht so den Blick in die Zukunft richten. Und ich wollte einfach auch vielleicht euch fragen. Als ich über Bochum nachgedacht habe, weil ich ja wusste, dass wir über sie sprechen, habe ich mich gefragt, welche Spieler bei Bochum haben diese Saison eigentlich wirklich überzeugt. So, dann bin ich– als Düsseldorfer fällt es mir schwer, aber bin ich an Timo Horn, auf Timo Horn gestoßen im Tor, ja. In der Hinrunde überragend, jetzt immer noch gut. Und auf jeden Fall Shooting Star Kajetan Lenz, wurde ja heute auch verkündet, dass er jetzt nach Hoffenheim gehen wird. Du hast ihn schon genannt, Francis Onyeka vielleicht noch, und Philipp Hofmann haben wir erwähnt, und Kojimi Yoshi. Ja, und dann wird es für mich ehrlicherweise schon sehr dünn. Ich weiß nicht, ob, ne? Also ich finde, es ist halt eine Mischung aus einem Trainer, der in gewissen Situationen, um das Team zu stabilisieren, da ist er sehr, sehr gut. Aber um jetzt vielleicht was Neues aufzubauen, das war zumindest meine Erfahrung in Düsseldorf, vielleicht nicht die ideale Wahl. Und dann eben ein Kader, der nicht gut zusammengestellt ist. Ich glaube, das muss man ganz klar so sagen. Auch hier war ja das Zielaufstieg zu Saisonbeginn. Da hat man sich ähnlich vertan wie in Düsseldorf, muss man sagen. Da fehlt es dann, also klar, Philipp Hofmann ist da im Sturm, aber die meisten anderen Offensivkräfte und Stürmer haben nicht überzeugt diese Saison. Und Hofmann war ja gerade zu Saisonbeginn noch gar nicht fit. Du hattest es eben schon mal, glaube ich, kurz angedeutet. Also da fehlte es gerade, aber auch dann eben an spielerischen Ideen. Ich meine, es ist ein großes Glück, dass Onjeka eingeschlagen ist, aber der kam, glaube ich, als 19-Jährige aus Leverkusen als Leihspieler. Da gibt es überhaupt keine Garantien. Leute wie Matos Spiero, Kapitän und slowakischer Nationalspieler, für mich eine komplett enttäuschende Saison. Er hat natürlich auch zwischendurch etwas länger verletzt. Also ich glaube, dieser Kader braucht einfach wirklich– und er wird auch kommen, weil natürlich auch einige Leihspieler dabei sind, aber der braucht eine Grundauffrischung. Und dann muss man sich halt die Trainerfrage stellen, ob man mit Röstar weitermachen möchte, ihm das zutraut oder eben nicht.
Ja, ich gehe vielleicht erst einmal rein. Nur, dass er ganz am Anfang die Frage gestellt, quasi so ein bisschen die Rollen vertauscht. Ja, also es ist– ich glaube, das war ja genau das, was wir– also die Bochum nicht als Ausstiegskandidaten getippt hatten zu Beginn der Saison. Genau, das war damals schon so mein Kritikpunkt. Also einmal, Anna, du hast es im Vorgespräch gesagt, die Dialogging hat man irgendwie so ein bisschen verdrängt. Und natürlich liegt eben viel an Dirktuf naht, dass das nicht alles in der Winterpause behoben werden konnte, war auch klar. Nicht jeder kann so erfolgreiche Transfers auch aus einer, ich sage mal, Position der Euphorie hertätigen wie Schalke 04, wo man ja wirklich sagen muss, also neben Oshish, Lovicic, Deku ist das schon wirklich schwierig, wenn du sonst so ne Neuzugang im Winter warst. Aber ich finde es halt interessant, weil ich erinnere mich noch sehr gut daran, dass wir zur Hinrundenbilanz. Gab es eben ein Kommentar eines Bochumer Fans, der eben gesagt hat, dass ja alles schön und gut, was Rösler geschafft hat jetzt in der Hinrunde und wir haben uns stabilisiert und wir sind aus dieser akuten Abstiegsgefahr hin raus. Aber er erwartet von ihm halt, dass jetzt diese Quick-Fixes vorbei sind. Und man muss halt dann ehrlich sagen, ich gehe mal davon aus, genau die gleiche Voraussetzung gab es intern auch. Also wie sieht denn die Rückrunde aus? Wie sieht da die Entwicklung aus? Und da finde ich dann schon, dass du es eben nicht nur alleine am Kader festmachen kannst. Weil, also, wie gesagt, du hattest dieses 2-0 gegen Dresden, wo Dresden einfach im Gegensatz zu dem Fortuna-Spiel in einer ganz anderen Position war. Und wie gesagt, man muss hier in diesem Spiel einfach mal sagen, eigentlich musst du führt in dieses, also, du musst entweder viel früher das 3-0 machen. Aber ich hatte auch so das Gefühl, nach dem Abseitstor dachten sie auch so, ja, aber es ist ja gefallen, das Tor. Also, es zählt jetzt zwar nicht, aber was soll denn jetzt noch groß passieren? Und das, also, das fand ich ganz, ganz fatal. Und man muss wirklich fragen, ob eine andere Mannschaft da in dem Tag sie nicht mehr wirklich bestraft hätte. Und sie haben jetzt eben selber sich diesen Matchball hingelegt. Man hat 6 Punkte auf einem direkten Abstiegsplatz. Man kann gegen Bielefeld am Wochenende den Klassen halt faktisch klar machen. Aber ich sag mal so, wenn du doch spielst gegen, wie gegen Dresden und führt, Bielefeld, reden wir gleich auch nochmal drüber. Dann wird das, glaube ich, nicht so der Selbstläufer, wie die denken, dass das wird. Anna?
Sie hatten ja einfach diese Momente, in denen sie vom Gegner wirklich arg, arg, arg da unten in diesen Tabellenbereich hätten reingezogen werden können. Sie schlagen Eintracht Braunschweig 4 zu 1 zu Hause. In der Summe absolut in Ordnung. War kein gutes Spiel von der Braunschweiger Eintracht auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite. War ich so ein bisschen ratlos über die großen Euphorie-Stürme des Kommentators über diesen großartigen Fußball, weil ich einfach das Gefühl hatte, der Ball fliegt nach vorne und da ist dann eben Philipp Hofmann. Also was soll man machen? Und wäre konjunktiv, wenn wir dieses Spiel gewonnen hätten, dann wären die eben richtig tief wieder mit dabei gewesen, weil sie davor gegen Abstiegskonkurrenz Magdeburg und Kiel verloren haben. Und ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass die Mannschaft– das passt vielleicht auch zu dem, was du gerade beschrieben hast– sich so ein bisschen auch für too big, too fail hält. Weiß ich nicht genau, dafür habe ich zu wenig in Gänze gesehen. Könnte mir aber vorstellen, dass– also ja, dass das– weil sonst machst du da den Deckel drauf. Und eierst da, eierst diese Partie nicht so zu Ende, weil Föhrt ja grundsätzlich auch sogar noch ausgleichen kann. Aber vielleicht zählt es auch auf das, was Thorsten vorhin über seine Fortuna gesagt hat. Nimmst du es wirklich so richtig, richtig ernst? Hast du wirklich im Kopf, dass du da unten richtig tief mit reinrutschen kannst? Kennst du die Dynamik, die dann zum Tragen kommt? Ich weiß es nicht. Da müssen vereins nähere Personen das bewerten. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass bei den Namen, die dort auf dem Platz stehen, man annimmt, dass es einem sowieso nicht passiert.
Ja, finde ich sehr interessant, weil ich kenne die Situation ja einfach mit Bielefeld von vor drei Jahren, wo man dann auch immer irgendwann dachte, too big, too fail, so nach dem Motto. Es sind sechs Punkte, und ich sage es gerne auch nochmal, aber was zum Beispiel auch hier ist, sie haben halt einen Plus-Eins-Tor-Verhältnis, das unterscheidet sie zu sehr vielen Vereinen da unten. Aber wenn du sie halt zum Beispiel mit Dresden und Bielefeld und so mixt, ist das halt dann doch nicht wieder so gut. Und dann musst du halt am Ende sagen, na klar, klingt doch ein Platz 10 schon noch besser als ein Platz 14 am Ende der Saison zum Beispiel. Und also ich kann da, ich habe den schon öfter mal in dieser Saison empfohlen, den 1848-Blog. Da hängt auch ein Podcast dran, aber ich finde vor allem den Blog sehr gut. Und die eben auch in dem Spielbericht, den habe ich euch verlinkt in den Show notes zu diesem Spiel, eben genau auch diese Fragen stellen. Wie geht es denn eigentlich weiter? Und jetzt eben auch eben mit Blick auf die Partie von Bochum und Bielefeld gesagt haben, also vor diesem Spieltag war übrigens Bielefeld die schlechteste Auswärtsmannschaft der Liga. Das ist alles sehr nah da unten beieinander. Aber also das Hinspiel, das war ein furchtbares Fußballspiel, wo Bochum eben am Ende durch diese individuelle Klasse, die sie dann halt doch anders hatten als Bielefeld, gewonnen hat. Aber ja, also danach geht es halt gegen Hannover und KSC. KSC ist so, die machen entweder das oder das gerade. Die haben vielleicht, wollen eben Eichner einen guten Abschluss liefern, glaube ich auch einfach.
Und es ist auswärts, also nicht zu Hause gegen Karlsruhe, sondern auswärts.
Und das finde ich, also mir, also ich gehe da zum Beispiel auch mit, Anna. Ich finde, also den Kommentator, also ich habe da sowieso immer ein Problem damit. Das liegt natürlich auch qua meiner Vereinszugehörigkeit, kann ich dem VfL Bochum per se relativ wenig abgewinnen. Aber es war dann auch so, ja, Philipp Hofmann, der Harry Kane, der der 2.
Liga.
Und ich war inzwischen so, ja, okay, da war jetzt an 8 Toren beteiligt in den letzten vier Spielen. Und ja, du merkst, wenn er nicht da ist. Aber uff, so. Und dann halt auch irgendwie dieser Vergleich zu dem Marathonläufer, der an dem Tag unter zwei Stunden. Ja, ich bin mir sicher, wenn man Philipp Hofmann da jetzt hinstellen würde, der würde auch unter zwei Stunden laufen. Ich weiß nicht, also Philipp Hofmann war jetzt nicht so bekannt als schnellster Spieler der 2. Bundesliga. Gut, ich kann halt sowas. Und dafür habe ich dann nämlich auch manchmal das Gefühl, dass das der Blick nach außen dann auch trügt, weil ich hatte nämlich auch nicht das Gefühl, weder vom Publikum her noch von der Mannschaft auf dem Rasen, dass da so richtig angekommen ist, dass das Ding hier noch nicht durch ist. Und das kann halt einfach richtig, richtig gefährlich werden. Und wie gesagt, ich sage es nochmal, es gibt jetzt am Wochenende eben diese Partie gegen Bielefeld. Sie haben bisher dann am Ende immer die nötigen Punkte geholt. Aber man muss natürlich dann trotzdem auch sagen, inwiefern spielt der Abstieg aus der letzten Saison, das ist jetzt eher so eine psychologische Frage, bei manchen Spielern dann vielleicht auch nochmal eine Rolle. So, weil das ist halt, also wie gesagt, ich gehe per se nicht davon aus, dass der Vorfall Bochum noch absteigt. Also, um nochmal klarzumachen, ich bin weiterhin der Meinung, die sind gesichert. Aber das, was sie eben beide auch schon gesagt haben, so ein bisschen, haben sie sich auch darauf ausgesucht, dass sie in dieser Position waren. Und das dürfen sie halt am Wochenende, also meinetwegen können sie das ja gerne machen, dürfen sie natürlich aus rein sportlicher Sicht natürlich auf gar keinen Fall machen. Und das ist halt, ja, also natürlich ist das auch gut, weil Philipp Hofmann in einer gewissen Weise, er steht dann da halt auch, aber persiv finde ich zum Beispiel auch da, das konnte man zum Teil auch mehr mit der führter Defensive, die wieder so ein bisschen außerwiegender Hinrunde erklären, als dass das jetzt reine bochumer taktische Meisterleistung war.
Definitiv, also das ist auch mein Eindruck aus dem Spiel gegen Braunschweig, das ich leider komplett gesehen habe, dass das jetzt nicht ein glänzendes 4-1-Galer-Stück gewesen ist, sondern dass der Gegner sehr schlecht war und dass das individuell an dem Tag einfach gepasst hat, weil zwei Spieler gesagt haben, wir betonieren jetzt unseren Ex-Verein. Liebe Grüße, vielen Dank. Das war sehr unangenehm. Aber nicht besonders schön. Sorry to say.
Wir haben Bochum in beiden Spielen besiegt. Darum kenne ich sie sowieso nur als unterlegenes Team.
Natürlich.
Eins von zwei Teams. Diese Saison gibt mir wirklich wenig. Das andere ist Paderborn. Also unsere beiden Schwerpunkt-Teams, die wir beide besiegt haben. Mit Fürth können wir es noch schaffen. Aber ja, ich bin da bei euch. Und wie gesagt, für mich ist aber auch spannend die Frage. Und ich glaube, ehrlicherweise auch, weil einfach zu viele Teams dazwischen sind auch, die sich ja die Punkte auch gegenseitig wegnehmen will, sagen, die können nicht alle gleichzeitig gewinnen in den letzten drei Spielen, dass für Bochum wahrscheinlich nichts mehr anbrennen wird. Und dann stellt sich halt für mich wirklich die Frage, wie geht es bei Bochum weiter? Das finde ich ist eine sehr spannende Frage nächsten Sommer, weil auch das Stadion ja umgebaut wird. Und wir haben es ja gerade festgestellt, also die Heimstärke ist da. Und aus neutraler Sicht ist das auch eins der cooleren Stadien der Liga. Da würde mir wahrscheinlich niemand widersprechen, dass es vielleicht doch ein bisschen cooler ist in Bochum als in Elbersberg. Sorry an alle Elbersberg-Fans.
Ich möchte nur noch mal sagen, ich möchte weiterhin keine Umbau von irgendwelchen Stadien bezahlen. Also weil ich sage nochmal 42,50 für diese Sitzplätze.
Jetzt wird hier jetzt umgebaut. Für 91,9 Millionen.
Sie sagen, es ist das beste Stadion NRWs oder so.
Naja, der Zustand nicht, aber es hat natürlich einen gewissen Scham. Das würde ich dem Stadion durchaus zugestehen. Die Sanitäranlagen sollen auch… Also vielleicht gibt es demnächst mal Pissoirs. Das wäre mal was aus männlicher Sicht, um hier mal aus dem Neck zu plaudern. Da habe ich gleich… Ja, genau. Gar nicht ganz genau. Unangenehm. Unangenehm, ja. Das kann man ja sagen.
Für ihn eine gute Nachhau.
Aber das liegt darauf, das Stadion wird teilweise auf eine Kapazität von nur 18.000 zurückfallen in den nächsten drei Jahren. Das kann sich natürlich auch negativ auswirken. Wir haben gerade eben ja festgestellt, dass der VfL dieses Stadion durchaus braucht. Und man wird also auch sehen, auch sowas ist nicht zwingend ein Vorteil, zumal der ganze Stadionumbau, dem VfL eigentlich nur etwas moderneres, aber nicht gerade ein einnahmetechnisch verbessertes Stadion liefern wird, was man so hört. Ja, also viel im Umbruch im Bochum, glaube ich, kann man zusammenfassen.
Sie werden nächste Saison, ich glaube, da sind wir uns jetzt alle eigentlich weiterhin, eine Rolle in diesem Podcast spielen. Bevor wir jetzt auf unsere letzten beiden Vereine kommen und dann Anna und ich noch so ein bisschen, weiß ich nicht, gute Laune, vielleicht auch per se schlechte Laune, wissen wir, glaube ich, noch nicht so ganz verbreiten können, kommen wir zu unserer Feedback-Schleife. Erstmal vielen lieben Dank für das ganze positive Feedback zur letzten Folge. Also es war quasi, spiegelte das wieder, was wir trotz der angekündigten schlechten Launefolge hatten. Und sorry nochmal, dass das so lange gedauert hat, bis das Video um war. Ja, manchmal hasst mich die Technik einfach. Ich kann euch leider immer noch nicht so zu 100 Prozent sagen, woran das gelegen hat, was einen immer tierisch beruhigt. Sonst ist natürlich der Hinweis, ihr kennt es. Der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich dadurch, dass ihr uns unterstützt unter www.rasenfunk.de/supportusclub. Da könnt ihr euch darüber informieren, wie man eben supporter wird. Mehr Infos auch in den Show Notes. Und auf der Webseite seht ihr eben auch nochmal eine Aufteilung. Also da gibt es auch einen Unterstützen-Button. Da könnt ihr euch auch ganz schnell dadurch registrieren. Und ihr könnt da tatsächlich auch sehen, inwieweit das, was ihr spendet, eben an Prozenten in die verschiedenen Bereiche fließt. Zum Beispiel, wie viel an Prozenten an Marc und mich gehen, an unsere Gäste, an den Rasenfunk an sich. Also wenn ihr es noch nicht seid, dann überlegt doch, ob ihr das werdet. Und vor allem auch im Hinblick darauf, was Max schon wieder abgeliefert hat. Also es sind Sendungen zur Bundesliga der Männer und Frauen erschienen. Vor allem die Sendung der Frauen, die hat dann mal wieder alleine gewuppt, mal ebenso zwischendurch in diesen Spieltag rein. War eine kurze Sendung, es sind nur zwei Stunden. Also ich finde, also zwei Stunden Monolog von Max, was kann es besseres geben? Außerdem ist letzte Woche eine Ligatour zu den europäischen Ligen erschienen. Und am Donnerstag, da erscheint dann vielleicht für viele Fans der lange erwartete Schwerpunkt zum VfB Stuttgart. Sonst hier natürlich auch nochmal der Hinweis, ich freue mich sehr über Input, Input-Thread zu den Zweitligatouren. Da seid ihr auch immer fleißig am Schreiben dabei. Da mag ich eigentlich auch sehr, wie eben diskutiert wird. Man haltet das gerne bei. Gibt manchmal auch Jörn Blickwinkel auf die Themen, die man so vielleicht nicht hatte. Und natürlich auch vielen Dank für eure Hinweise immer zum Feedback. Deshalb ich hoffe an die Person, die geschrieben hat, ich lese, verlese die Zahlen zu schnell. Ich hoffe, es war jetzt besser. Und du kannst besser deine Hausarbeit erledigen, nebenher. Sorry, ich ratte das immer so ein bisschen runter. Auch in der Angst, dass ich mich sonst verspreche, was nicht so ganz logisch klingt. Aber naja, ja, wie komme ich jetzt von Angst auf den nächsten Verein? Es geht um Aminia Bielefeld. Es ist Platz 13, 35 Punkte, 46 zu 47 Tore, 9 Siege, 8 Unentschieden und 14 Niederlagen. In der Formtabelle ist man auf Platz 9, 2 Siege, 1 Unentschieden und 2 Niederlagen. Nach der klaren Niederlage gegen Karlsruhe folgte ein merkwürdiges Spiel gegen Nürnberg, was am Ende 1 zu 1 ausging. Und jetzt am Wochenende der Derby-Sieg gegen Münster. Nach einem frühen 0-1-Rückstand, dann mit drei Toren in 23 Minuten. Da war mal wieder diese Selbstverständlichkeit da eigentlich, die man mal entwickelt hat im Laufe der Saison. Nach Führung dann auch mal mehr zu treffen. Und endlich drei Tore aus Standard- beziehungsweise Standard-ähnlichen Situationen. Ich sag jetzt schon mal, also mein Tor des Monats ist da gefallen. Ich wusste nicht. Also man muss dazu sagen, mal Corbis vergibt sehr kläglich aus fünf Metern gerne mal vom Tor, aber einen Hackentrick, den kann er dann auspacken zum 3-1. Aber es wäre nicht Amina Bielefeld, wenn man es zum Ende nicht nochmal spannend macht. In der zweiten Halbzeit war das, ja ich sag mal, für die Bielefelder Seele nicht so ganz angenehm zu gucken. Macht am Ende eben noch einen Eigentor von Maxi Großer für zum 2-3. Bielefeld mit den meisten Rückständen der Liga, aber wenigstens noch 19 Punkte geholt, 4 Siege, 7 Remis. Nach 14 Führungen 9 Mal gewonnen übrigens, 1 Remis, 4 Niederlagen. Ja, also ich kann ja einmal ganz kurz nur sagen, dass man wusste vor diesem Spiel, der Druck ist groß. Also ich kann aus Bielefelder Sicht sagen, nach diesem 1-1 gegen Nürnberg, also diese Partien, Karlsruhe, Nürnberg war bei sehr, sehr vielen Fans. Eigentlich genau der Schritt in die falsche Richtung. Da hatte man echt so ein bisschen das Gefühl, okay, ist euch irgendwie bewusst, wo ihr seid und was hier gerade eigentlich passiert. Und man muss sagen, also klar, man gerät früh in Rückstand, aber die Reaktion, die die Mannschaft auf diesen Rückstand gezeigt hat, die war wirklich bemerkenswert. Und das war auch so ein bisschen das, was man aus der Mannschaft daraus gehört hat. Und jetzt natürlich aber, Anna, ich würde dich mal als erstes fragen, also ihr seid ja beide eher daran interessiert, dass Bielefeld jetzt nicht punktet, das ist mir auch durchaus bewusst. Ja, ja, ihr wollt den Host hier nicht verärgern, ist schon klar.
Dass du mir so was unterstellst. Von mir kam nie ein böses Wort.
Aber Anna, vielleicht mal von dir erstmal, wie würdest du denn diesen Sieg jetzt am Wochenende gegen Münster aus Bielefelder Sicht bewerten?
Es ist natürlich ein Brett. Ich habe ja das Wochenende nicht nur in Kaiserslautern verbracht, sondern auch in Karlsruhe. Und dort meinen Lebens- und Derby-Partner zum Spiel gegen den KSD begleitet. Auch sehr gute Beinschorle übrigens im Weltpark. Mit mehr Wasser aber.
Welche war besser?
Kommt auf die Parameter an. Wumms in Kaiserslautern, erfrischender Karlsruhe. The true is your fighter. Und genau, in der größeren Gruppe unterwegs gewesen und irgendwann schlicht sich dann das Gedankenspiel ein, wie es sich wohl anfühlen würde, im Abstiegskampf einen Derby spielen zu müssen, bei dem beide im Abstiegskampf einfach relevant involviert sind und ich möchte das auf gar keinen Fall. Das stelle ich mir wirklich uneingeschränkt schrecklich vor. Weil da sich irgendwie alles kombiniert, was man eben nicht haben möchte. Also du möchtest sowieso kein Derby verlieren und du möchtest jetzt auf gar keinen Fall durch eine Nidhida-Galllage im Derby noch tiefer in den Abstiegskampf gezogen werden oder sogar, dass es am Ende heißt, in diesem Moment stand der Abstieg fest. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass da ganz, ganz, ganz üble Gedankenspiele im Kopf waren, als Münster dann in Führung gegangen ist. Zumal Münster jetzt nach dem Trainerwechsel, darüber haben wir in der letzten Rasenfunk-Folge ja gesprochen, nicht unbedingt für furioses Torschießfeuerwerk steht, sondern eher für grundlegende Defensivarbeit und dann konzentriertes Vorgehen. Und in meinem Kopf wäre gewesen, okay, wir verlieren jetzt hier mit einem Gegentor und null eigenen Toren, tschau. Und ja, wie gesagt, also mein vollstes Mitgefühl dafür. Wir haben schon über diesen Schlusschor gesprochen. Bielefeld ist Derbysieger, finde ich super fantastisch. Ich möchte jetzt diesen Münster-Fangesang nicht zitieren, weil es ein Wort enthält, das ich nicht öffentlich sagen möchte. Aber genau, die Nachlese da gerne, die Stimmen nach dem Spiel sind bei YouTube zu hören und der Bielefelder Chor im Hintergrund. Ich glaube, dann ist die Verbindung klar. Ich glaube, dass das total viel machen kann, weil Bielefeld ja kommt aus dem Aufstieg nicht nur, sondern aus dem Pokalfinale. Und ich mir vorstellen kann, dass dieses Schulterschlussgefühl jetzt im Saisonfinale super, super, super wichtig ist, weil ihr ja eigentlich im Hinblick auf– also auf jeden Fall Vereinsmitglieder, vielleicht auch Dauerkartenverkäufe, Fragezeichen, kannst du gleich was zu sagen, wenn man die Topzahlen hat und unerreicht irgendwie bisher eigene Rekorde bricht. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das jetzt irgendwie wieder der X-Faktor sein wird, der vor Beginn oder zum Beginn der Saison dafür gesorgt hat, dass der Start ja super war. Und dass das jetzt vielleicht einfach so ein bisschen den Kreis schließt, da wieder anzuknüpfen und dass man daran erinnert worden ist, an diesem letzten Spieltag.
Ja, das ist ganz interessant, weil dieser Zusammenschluss ist ja das, was eigentlich schon seit einer sehr langen Zeit eigentlich schon, als man quasi mit einem Bein in der 4. Liga stand, ist dieser dieser Slogan zusammen halt triumfiert. Und das ist, also man muss das in Bielefeld, ich habe das schon mal gesagt, aber wirklich auch, wir haben halt diesen Vergleich, diese Saison von vor drei Jahren, wo du eben am Ende abgestiegen bist, auch weil du am letzten Spiel gegen Magdeburg halt irgendwie komplett seelenlos 04 verlierst und dann kommen diese Relegationsspiele gegen Wiesbaden. Und du merkst einfach, das war halt ab diesem Abstieg sehr vielen Bielefeld-Fans wichtig und ich glaube, das war dem Verein auch wichtig. Wir müssen irgendwie alle wieder zusammenarbeiten. Und man muss halt sagen, das ist gleichzeitig Stärke und natürlich auch ein Problem, weil wie willst du Mannschaft und vielleicht auch Fans verklickern nach diesem Aufstieg, nach dem Pokalfinale? Wir müssen diese Mannschaft jetzt auseinanderreißen, weil die Hälfte von denen, ob die jetzt 2. Liga-tauglich ist, don't know. Und du siehst das, also ich möchte das überhaupt nicht kleinreden, du siehst natürlich in Spielen in dieser Saison, dass ein Teil dieses Teams einfach nicht 2. Liga-tauglich ist. Das muss man, glaube ich, einfach wirklich so bescheinigen. Ich muss an der Stelle, auch weil es ein bisschen im Forum aufkam, ehrlich gesagt ein paar Bielefeld-Fans auch kritisieren, weil ich von dieser Hühn-Hot-Kultur relativ wenig halte. Also im Sommer war nach den zwei Siegen zu Beginn alles toll. Jetzt ist irgendwie alles scheiße und man hat im Sommer nur falsche Entscheidungen getroffen und so wieso. Und mit Knien halt bis zum Ende der Saison und Tiestas. Und hier Kersken macht in jedem Spiel einen Fehler. Halte ich für genau den falschen Weg, ehrlich gesagt, weil ich sage das gerne nochmal. Es ist manchmal einfacher, als Mannschaft aufzusteigen und sich dann neu zu formieren. Weil zum Beispiel bei Dynamo Dresden war es dann schon einfacher, vielleicht im Winter zwei, drei Spieler neu zu integrieren, als es bei Aminia Bielefeld der Fall war. Und trotzdem, ne, und das ist halt einfach schwierig. Dann verletzt sich noch ein Joel Felix, dann würde hier irgendwie geschrieben, ja, Bielefeld macht seinen Zusammenhalt kaputt, weil er Knoche und Bauer koffen, wo ich es ganz klar sagen muss. Also sollen wir einfach mit einem Innenverteidiger die restliche Saison spielen? Oder wie stellen die Leute sich das vor? Und das ist wirklich so ein bisschen mein Kritikpunkt, weil ich habe dann heute gesehen, dass jemand aufgelistet hat, die Fehler welcher Spieler in welchem Spiel gemacht hat. Das finde ich drei Spieltage vor Schluss nach dem Derbysieg genau das falsche Zeichen, weil das bringt uns jetzt nichts, weil genau das, worüber wir am Wochenende gekommen sind, also wir, sage ich, die Mannschaft, aber eben auch der Zusammenschluss, Fans, Team auf dem Rasen, das ist das, wo du jetzt die letzten drei Spiele eben machen musst. Und das finde ich sehr merkwürdig und gerade auch, also ich verstehe zum Teil die Kritik an Jonas Kersgen, aber ich möchte das trotzdem nochmal sagen, für einen Großteil dieser Mannschaft war das das erste 2. Liga-Jahr. Ja, und die sind zum Teil auch in einem gehobenen Alter, das ist gemischt, dass da nicht alle gleich die Saison ihres Lebens spielen. Okay, so. Und gerade finde ich die Kritik an Jonas Kersgen nach diesem Wochenende ehrlich gesagt nicht angebracht, weil meiner Meinung nach ist Kersgen, als der Rest der Mannschaft so ein bisschen gepennt hat hinten, der hat Bielefeld zweitermal im Spiel gehalten. Ja, er sieht da nicht gut aus beim 2 zu 3, aber ohne ihn stellen es halt vorher vielleicht schon ein entschieden. So. Das ist einfach mein Appell, also sorry für den Rant und sorry für mein Monolog gerade, aber das ist tatsächlich mein Appell an die restlichen Aminia-Fans. Wir können im Sommer alles neu bewerten. Und ich bin der festen Überzeugung, genau das wird Michael Mutzel machen, es wird auch Mitch Kniehart machen, da werden schon, also wenn sie es nicht machen, dann können wir da nochmal drüber diskutieren, aber ich habe, ich verstehe nicht so ganz, wonach in den letzten drei Jahren oder zwei Jahren oder drei Jahren dieses tiefe Misstrauen auf einmal herkommt. Und das finde ich tatsächlich sehr gefährlich und einfach wie gesagt finde ich unangebracht. Ich habe gleich noch einen zweiten Rantpunkt, aber ich möchte einmal erst Thorsten dazu holen, um vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen die Runde zu schließen. Ich war ja bei euch zu Gast zu Beginn der Rückrunde und da haben wir ja eigentlich gesagt, ja Bielefeld, die werden vielleicht jetzt nicht genau die gleiche Punkte holen, nicht die gleichen Spiele gewinnen wie in der Hinrunde. Aber die werden schon ihre Punkte holen. Jetzt muss man sagen, man hat jetzt in der Rückrunde 16 Punkte bisher geholt. In der Hinrunde waren es 19 insgesamt. Wie würdest du denn per se auf Bielefeld gucken? Was macht dir vielleicht auch aus neutraler Sicht, was sagst du, was sind jetzt die Punkte, die im Endspurt helfen?
Also grundsätzlich finde ich nach wie vor, dass Aminia Bielefeld häufig zumindest was Seriöses anbietet. Also ihr faltet auch irgendwie selten auseinander oder so etwas, oder dass man das Gefühl hat, diese Mannschaft ist jetzt nicht mit dem Herzen dabei. Also gerade mindset, die soften Fakten, die stimmen bei der Aminia. Und ich glaube auch, dass mit Kniet einfach ein sehr guter Fit ist und dass das passt. Er hat ja auch ein ganz interessantes Spielsystem, was ja manchmal so fast ein bisschen chaotisch wirkt, aber immer noch natürlich hohe Intensität gegen Pressing und so weiter. Wenn man sich die Werte auch anguckt bei Bielefeld, da seid ihr wirklich ganz weit oben. Gefühlt können die Ergebnisse manchmal nicht mithalten. Und das ist, glaube ich, genau das, was du gesagt hast. Weiter fehlt es hier und da ein bisschen nicht nur an 2. Liga-Erfahrung, sondern vielleicht auch an Qualität. Es gibt so ein paar Leute, die herausragen jetzt– zuletzt ja Monjuo Momolo– sehr auffällig. Und der gefällt mir auch wirklich super. Es fehlt so ein bisschen bei euch der Torjäger vorne drin. Also klar, Grudowsky hat seine neun Tore als schneller Umschaltstürmer, aber ist nicht so ein Zielspieler wie Hofmann, wie Itten oder Ähnliches, die einem da vielleicht auch noch mal ein bisschen weiterhelfen. Das ist schon ein Defizit. Und ich muss auch sagen, so richtig gut hat das Winter-Transfer-Fenster aus meiner Sicht dann nicht geklappt. Also ja, Knoche ist aus meiner Sicht wirklich eine Verstärkung, finde ich. Hat euch da sehr stabilisiert. Maximilian Bauer sehe ich schon seit seiner Lauternzeit eher immer etwas kritischer. Und ja, Telalovic, ich glaube, er hat neulich jetzt endlich mal sein Tor gemacht, aber ist ein Spieler, bei dem ich mir aktuell nicht so ganz sicher bin, ob er wirklich ein Zweitligamann ist. Und auch Rochelt wartet jetzt schon sehr lange auf eine wirklich gute Halbserie mal wieder. Vielleicht hast du da noch ein bisschen andere Meinung, dass er jetzt langsam kommt oder so. Aber ich sag mal so, ihr hattet jetzt nicht so ein Winter-Transferfenster wie Dynamo Dresden. Und wenn wir auf die Hinrunde gucken, wo ja Dresden ganz klar schlechter als Bielefeld war in praktisch allen Belangen, muss man sagen, weil ihr beide auch die Aufsteiger seid und man das ein bisschen vergleichen kann, da hat Dresden im Winter es geschafft, die Qualität etwas höher zu steigern, als das bei Bielefeld der Fall war. Und gefühlt stimmt es aber eigentlich von außen betrachtet an so vielen Stellen, dass es eigentlich wirklich sehr tragisch wäre, wenn das am Ende irgendwie in einem Abstieg münden würde, weil genau wie du gesagt hast, gefühlt wird da gerade was aufgebaut wieder in Bielefeld, was kaputtgegangen war. Und Aufbau, das weiß man im Fußball, braucht Zeit, auch wenn man die nie hat. Und darum kann ich deinen Appell an die Leute oder Bielefeld-Fans schon verstehen. Man ist eben jetzt nicht automatisch durch den Wiederaufstieg wieder eine Mannschaft, die höhere Ambitionen als Klassenerhalt feiern kann. Dafür schlagen so zwei Jahre in der 3. Liga auch allein finanziell so sehr ins Kontor. Das muss man erstmal wieder aufholen. Ich glaube, Braunschweig kennt das Gefühl auch. Ich hoffe, dass uns dieser Cage erspart bleibt. Weil da einfach sehr viel kaputt geht. Darum, ja, es wird nicht einfach, weil immer wieder so ein bisschen diese Spiele dabei sind, wo man sagt, das Ergebnis, dieses 1-1 gegen Nürnberg, ich habe es nur in der Zusammenfassung gesehen, aber war wohl scheinbar kein gutes Spiel in irgendeiner Form. Man spürt der Mannschaft wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen den Druck. Also man merkt ja das an, aber was ich eingangs sagte, ich finde, die Einstellung stimmt eigentlich von außen betrachtet immer bei Bielefeld. Das ist ja ein Thema, das hatten wir eben, das ist vielleicht bei Bochum oder Düsseldorf, bei anderen im Abstiegskampf nicht immer so der Fall und das kann am Ende vielleicht dann auch noch den Ausschlag geben.
Ja, so ein bisschen positiv hat mich tatsächlich gestimmt, dass man jetzt eben zwei Spiele vom Ergebnis her anders gestalten konnte als in der Hinrunde. Also man hat eben die Partie, die war ähnlich furchtbar in der Hinrunde, die Partie gegen Nürnberg, aber die hat man eben 2 zu 0 verloren. Hier konnte man eben, also am Ende war mir relativ egal, wie man dieses 1-1, also dieses Unentschieden holt. Ich finde, dann ist halt tatsächlich immer wichtig, ja, Aussagen, die nach außen getroffen werden, auch nicht immer gut, aber wie wird das intern aufgearbeitet. Und da hatte ich eben schon das Gefühl, dass da, genauso wie im Karlsruhe-Spiel, dann in der Zweieinhalbstatt schon die Einstellungen-Problem war. Und das war eben, also, hätte die Einstellung nicht gepasst in dieser Partie gegen Münster, dann verlierst du das eben genauso, Anna, wie du es eben beschrieben hast. Und das war eben nicht der Fall. Und Mal Corvus hat zum Beispiel auch gesagt, also da war es eben auch, da waren Fans beim Training. Es gab eben auch vor dem Spiel nochmal dieses Einschwören mit der Mannschaft, vor dem Block, das spielt dann eben schon einen Unterschied. Und dann war das Derby wahrscheinlich dann doch nochmal so ein positiver Kick. Du hast jetzt am Wochenende aus mehreren Gründen eben das nächste Highlight-Spiel. Also eben ist Bochum eben auch so ein Nordrhein-Westfalen-Derby. Let's Fight, sag's doch! Nee, also es hat auch was damit zu tun. Wer es nicht weiß, Bochum und Münster auflegen eine Fan-Freundschaft. Also das heißt, und Bielefeld und Münster sind eben verhasst, kann man glaube ich schon so sagen. Und das ist deshalb schon so ein Prestigeting, vor allem, weil man eben beide Partien in der Hinrunde verloren hat. Und da hast du dann auch gesehen, da hat es dann auch das SMA-Fan-Technisch so ein bisschen gekippt, weil du eben diese Spiele willst halt nicht verlieren. Es steht dann eben auch noch der 121. Geburtstag an. Und es ist 100-jähriges Juwiläum der Alm. Also seit 1926 gibt es eben das Stadion Alm. Es heißt seit 2004 Schiko-Arena. Es nennt es niemand so, außer Aminia in ihrer offiziellen Kommunikation. Das ist ein Rabbit Hole. Also ich könnte mich tierisch darüber aufregen, dass überall, also es wurde groß angekündigt, ja für den Tag heißt das Stadion wieder Alm. Aber dann heißt es überall, ja hier hinten auf den Trikots und so, Stadion an der Mainland-Schütternstraße und unser Zuhause. Ich finde es ganz furchtbar. Es ist wirklich, ja, ist für mich mehr Marketing-Kniff als wirklich ernst gemeinte Hommage an die Fans, was ich wirklich sehr schade finde. Aber man hat jetzt eben das Heimspiel gegen Bochum, dann Aussitz bei Kaiserslautern und dann Zuhause bei der Hertha. Und das waren eben in der Hinrundespiele, da hat man eben nur zwei Punkte geholt. Dieses ganz furchtbare 0-0 gegen Kaiserslautern und dieses 1-1 gegen Hertha, wo Russo da eben in der 90. Plus 6, glaube ich, noch dieses Ding reinschraubt. Da bin ich sehr, sehr gespannt, was wir da im sehen. Aber da muss man eben sagen, Anna, du hattest eben, glaube ich, gefragt, wegen Zuschauertalen, Mitglieder und so. Also, man muss sagen, dann stand jetzt, weil jedes Heimspiel heimseitig ausverkauft. Es gibt eben 17.000 Dauerkarten, das wurde am Anfang gedeckelt. Und man ist inzwischen bei einer Mitgliedszahl über 30.000. Das ist eben schon... Die Rekorde sind da. Natürlich weiß man nicht, wie viele bleiben übrig, aber wir haben das erstmal eine Warteliste für Dauerkarten und so. Also, das ist schon... Der Hype war die ganze Saison trotzdem über da. Also, ne, das war schon echt krass. Und natürlich für mich ist es noch so ein kleiner Innenminster. Man hat... Es ist ja gerade ein Neubau, ich möchte noch mal sagen. Für alle, die nach Münster auswärtsfahren müssen, demnächst, vielleicht auch in der 3. Liga, man weiß es nicht. Es ist schon sehr irritierend, dass vor dem Stehplatzbereich sind noch mal Drehkreuze. Vom Sitzplatzbereich nicht. Also, da musst du noch mal dein Ticket einscannen, fürs Reihen und fürs Rausgehen. Zwar gibt es auch ein Tor, aber ich halte das gerade, also wenn du mal in diesem Block wart, gerade aus, es gibt dann so einen Aufgang hoch quasi, einen Ausgang raus, erhalte ich das so aus, also ich weiß, Bielefelds Auswärtsblock ist furchtbar, aber wenn ich dann einen neu baue, dann verstehe ich nicht, wie ich ihn baue und wie sowas abgenommen werden kann. Auch in einer Situation, beispielsweise die Sicherheitsbeauftragte, bei der ich dann da war, die hat ihre Handschuhe noch nicht mal an, obwohl seit einer Viertelstunde 900 Fans vorgestanden. Das fand ich dann doch auch komisch. Na ja, also alles so Punkte, wo ich mich tatsächlich auch frage, also, Muenzert baut sich jetzt dieses neue Stadion, vielleicht ist deshalb auch das Problem. Also, für den Derby kam da, glaube ich, irgendwann auch nicht mehr so ganz das Stadion mit, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist gerade in der zweiten Halbzeit dann doch so ein bisschen eingeschlafen. Das kann natürlich dann auch– ich meine, klar, das ist finanziert und so, aber es ist natürlich trotzdem auch nicht schön, gerade mit einem neuen Stadion dann da in der dritten Liga mit anzutreten. Also, na, ja.
Sollen wir noch vielleicht zwei Worte zu Münster sagen, dass es vermutlich jetzt der besiegelte Abstieg war mit diesem Spiel? Es ist ein bisschen wie bei Bochum natürlich, ja, wenn man sich die Punkte anguckt, ist das natürlich theoretisch noch möglich. Aber auch hier wieder dasselbe Problem. Die Teams unten nehmen sich teilweise gegenseitig die Punkte weg. Und Münsters Restprogramm ist knüppelig. Also Hannover auswärts als Nächstes, dann zu Hause gegen Darmstadt und dann auswärts in Elbersberg. Die Reaktionen der Spieler haben es auch gezeigt nach dem Spiel. Da waren auch ein paar Tränen am Start etc. Ich befürchte, dass war diese Heimniederlage der entscheidende Punkt zum Abstieg. Und ja, ganz überraschend, ich glaube, wir waren uns da in der Rasenfunkgruppe sehr schnell einig, dass vielleicht Alois Schwarz als Neuverpflichtung nicht der absolute Schachzug ist, den man in dieser Situation bräuchte. Und ja, einen Sieg hat er noch nicht geholt, glaube ich, wenn man das richtig sieht, ein paar 0 zu 0s. Also, ehrlicherweise genau das, was man von Alois Schwarz erwarten darf. Sorry für den Diss an dieser Stelle, aber für mich kein Zweitligatrainer.
Ja, und ich finde, sie strahlen nach was anderes auch, auch in den Interviews nach dem Spiel, als die Vörter, die sich irgendwie in so eine fränkische Hypnose begeben haben, habe ich so das Gefühl. Also das ist ja wirklich eine, das geht aber auch von Heiko Vogel aus, wirklich ein stoisches Vorgehen dort in dieser Tabellenregion, die dann aber eben einfach so plötzlich aus der Kiste springen. Und ich grundsätzlich den Vörtern zutraue, was ich Münster aktuell nicht mehr zutraue, dass die noch mal eine überraschende, von niemandem antizipierte Serie hinlegen, weil irgendwie niemand so richtig weiß, warum Furt doll gewinnt und dann wieder doll verliert. Deswegen würde ich da tatsächlich sagen, weiß ich nicht genau, was passiert. Bei Münster habe ich den Vibe nicht, also auch nicht in den Interviews gehabt.
Wo du sie gerade reinbringst, Furt, natürlich auch nicht mit einem leichten Restprogramm. Sie spielen jetzt das Derby gegen den Klub. Das wird der Klub, der im Grunde gerettet ist, noch mehr als Bochum. Der Klub wird sehr ernst nehmen, weil es einfach das Derby ist. Dann spielen sie auswärts bei Hertha. Ja, Hertha ist keine Heim-Macht in dieser Saison, aber auch da wird man im letzten Heim-Spiel wahrscheinlich sehr motiviert sein, auch noch mal alles zu einem vernünftigen Ende zu bringen. Und dann kommt eben das Finale wahrscheinlich gegen Fortuna des Love.
Ja, aber sie hatten halt diese weirden Siege gegen Hannover und Elbersberg. Und seitdem traue ich Fjord einfach nicht mehr über Nick. Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Also, was weiß ich, was da passiert. Das und irgendwie finde ich das misstrauenerweckend. Aber irgendwie auch ganz cool, so richtig schlau werde ich da irgendwie nicht draußen, muss ich sagen. So viel sei mir zugestanden an Ratlosigkeit.
Und dann kommen wir zu unserem letzten Verein, nämlich zur Eintracht aus Braunschweig. Da ist es nur ein Platz unter Aminia Bielefeld, nämlich Platz 14, 34 Punkte, 34 zu 50 Tore, 9 Siege, 7 Unentschieden und 15 Niederlagen stehen da zu Buche. Die Formtabelle, die zeigt Platz 14. Vor allem dank eines Sieges am Wochenende. Davor waren es 2 Unentschieden, 2 Niederlagen, nach 4 Spielen ohne Sieg. Auch hier Düsseldorf war der letzte Sieg davor. Jetzt ein Sieg zum richtigen Zeitpunkt. Es gab eben dieses 2 zu 0 gegen Kaiserslautern am Freitagabend. Vielleicht erst mal, Anna, du warst da, du hast die Weinschorle genossen, hast du gesagt. Du hast gesagt, wenn ich zitieren darf, also Abschließkampf braucht auch kein Fußballspielen. Möchtest du das kurz erklären?
Ja, also ganz kurz ausgeholt. Wir hatten jetzt gerade eine Phase, in der wir durchaus Fußball gespielt haben, es nicht nur versucht haben, sondern tatsächlich ordentlich was mit dem Ball zustande bekommen haben. Auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite komplett ohne Ertrag. Also wir hatten zwar diesen Auftakt-Sieg, das meint, wir hatten einen Trainerwechsel. Mitte der Rückrunde, nachdem wir gegen Münster bedauerlicherweise verloren haben zu Hause in einem wirklich absolut erbärmlichen Zweitligaspiel, hat der vormalige Trainer Heiner Backhaus noch die Partie gegen Paderborn bekommen, wo ein 1-1 überraschend erzielt werden konnte. Zu dem Zeitpunkt stand laut Benjamin Kessel aber schon fest, dass der Trainer gehen wird und nur noch die Formalitäten geregelt werden mussten, dass Lars Konnetka da jetzt schalten und walten darf. Und der möchte nicht nur kontern und nicht nur warten und nicht nur Fehler ausnutzen, sondern tatsächlich aktiv ein Spiel gestalten, kontrollieren. Er möchte die aktive Mannschaft sein und aktiver grundsätzlich auch als der Gegner. Und das sah wirklich gut aus. Nach diesem 1 zu 0 gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf im Heimspiel folgte dann das Derby, in dem wir absolut nicht die schlechtere Mannschaft waren, trotzdem eben 1 zu 0 verlieren. Und dann folgte eine Durststrecke. Die Heimspieler haben wir immerhin nicht verloren, konnten sie aber auch nicht gewinnen. Auswärts sah es schlechter aus und ich war tatsächlich schon etwas beunruhigt, weil auf der einen Seite zeigte die Mannschaft ein spielerisch komplett anderes Gesicht und auch die Spieler sagten in Interviews, dass es sie freut, dass sie endlich einen Plan an die Hand bekommen. Und ich finde das immer so interessant, weil ja im Fußball dafür ist das Geschäft ja viel zu eng, weil niemand explizit schlecht übereinander spricht, aber dann nicht mal im Subtext, sondern irgendwo zwischen gesagtem Unsubtext, dann doch sehr deutlich zum Vorschein kommt, was für Defizite vorher offenbar da gewesen sein müssen. Und die Frage natürlich sich aber stellt, ist das zeitlich vielleicht einfach zu ambitioniert? Hat die Mannschaft zu wenig Möglichkeiten, in diese komplette Veränderung an Spielphilosophie reinzufinden? Beziehungsweise ist sie gut genug, dafür den Abstiegskampf spielerisch für sich zu entscheiden? Ich bin wirklich froh, dass Lars Konnetka sich nicht zu stolz war, um von dieser ursprünglichen Spielidee abzuweichen. Und in Kaiserslautern ein absolut freches Fußballspiel präsentiert hat, indem er ausgenutzt hat, dass Kaiserslautern trotz der nicht besonders aufregenden Rebellenregionen, in der der Verein gerade steht, zu Hause arg unter Druck stand, nachdem er in der Woche zuvor in Kiel abgefertigt worden ist und dann unter der Woche gesagt worden ist, man würde ein anderes Gesicht zeigen, man will sich bei den Fans revanchieren und so weiter und so fort. Und du halt arg gemerkt hast, nach dem Führungstreifer in der 14. oder 15. Minute, nach einem Torwartfehler des 18-jährigen 2. Liga-Debütanten, den wir für uns nutzen konnten, dass halt die Stimmung nach und nach kippt. Und ich würde sagen, dass wir weniger gegen Kaiserslautern gewonnen haben, als dass sie gegen sich selbst verloren haben. Und das war riskant, das hätte nicht aufgehen müssen. Ich bin sehr überrascht, dass gerade dieser Trainer sich für einen Spielansatz entschieden hat, der mündet in weniger als 30 Prozent Ballbesitz, 0,7 Expected Goals und zwei Toren. Aber vielleicht muss man auch einfach einsehen zu diesem Zeitpunkt in der Saison, wenn du eine Mannschaft dort übernimmst, wo sie steht, dass du nicht alles von ihr verlangen kannst. Spiel gestalten, Spiel dominieren, effektiv sein und hinten stabil stehen. Dass das einfach ein zu viel ist für ein Team, das auch keinen Footgoy hat und keinen Hoffmann, der vorne einfach steht und die Dinger macht und einen mehr als die Jungs hinten reinlassen. Und das steckt hinter dieser Aussage, also 27 Prozent Ballbesitz und ein schlitzohriges, also wir haben, das ist so witzig, wir haben einfach zwei Spiele mit mehr als einem Torunterschied gewonnen und das war das Hinspiel gegen Casas Lauten, 2 zu 0 und das Rückspiel auch 2 zu 0. Na ja, solche Geschichten schreibt nur der Fußball.
Thorsten, was hast du für positive Worte zur Eintracht-Braunschei zu verlegen oder warum hebst du hier deine Hand?
Ich habe zwei Punkte, die ich zu dieser Partie loswerden möchte. Das eine habe ich im Vorgespräch geteasert. Ihr wisst ja, dass der Kicker immer in seinen Aufstellungen am Ende ein kurzes Fazit zu einer Partie schreibt und eine Spielnote gibt. Und ich wollte Anna damit kurz konfrontieren und mal sehen, wie sie darauf reagiert. Also Kickerspielnote 6. Braunschweig spielte wie ein Absteiger und siegte dennoch verdient. Über die Leistung der Gastgeber ist damit alles gesagt. FCK-Sportdirektor Klos fasste es zusammen. Am Fernseher hätte man dieses Spiel wohl einfach ausgeschaltet. Fand ich schon krass als Zusammenfassung. Kannst du gleich was zu sagen, ob es vielleicht sogar stimmt. Und ich möchte ein bisschen outcallen, dass man in einem Abstiegskampf, in dem es für viele Mannschaften um sehr viel geht, dass man in einer Partie gegen einen Gegner, der mittendrin in diesem Abstiegskampf ist, seinen 18-jährigen Nachwuchstorhüter ein Zweitligaspiel schenkt und er dieses dann auch entsprechend beeinflusst. Innis Kamga ist ein großes Talent des deutscher U19-Nationalkeeper. Es steht außer Zweifel, dass das ein guter Junge ist. Darum geht es mir hier auch nicht. Sondern um dieses Geschmäckle, dass man den sportlichen Wettbewerb damit beeinflusst. Ich finde, das macht man einfach nicht. Das macht man am letzten Spieltag, wenn man gegen wen spielt, für den es auch um nichts geht. Das neue Trikot hat man von der neuen Saison schon an. Dann macht man das, aber nicht mitten im Abstiegskampf. Das wollte ich ein bisschen outcoilen, weil ich finde, das setzt auch bei einer Mannschaft das Signal. Und die lautere Leistung zeigt das ja. Ja, es ist jetzt irgendwie alles egal und vorbei. Jetzt machen wir auch mal sowas. Und so haben sie dann auch im Endeffekt gespielt. Ihr habt davon profitiert und dir wird das egal sein. Aber mich ärgert das logischerweise als Düsseldorfer total, wenn ich sehe, das wird so random einfach gemacht und entscheidet das Spiel dann. Das wollte ich kurz outcoilen. Darum ist lieber Knecht ein bisschen selber schuld, wenn er da jetzt richtig Unruhe in der Bude hat.
Ja, das kann ich grundsätzlich verstehen, hatte aber nicht den Eindruck, dass wir gegen eine Mannschaft gespielt haben, der es egal war, wie sie sich präsentiert. Ich habe, glaube ich, selten eine so heftige Publikumsreaktion mitbekommen. Die Leute sind gegangen und haben in der Halbzeit schon gepfiffen. Und nach Spielende war da– also all das, was vorher laut und positiv war, war immer noch laut, aber überhaupt nicht positiv. Ich frage mich, aus welchen konkreten Aspekten Kaisers Lauten einen Anspruch artikuliert, dem man so wenig gerecht geworden ist, dass es eine so krasse Unzufriedenheit rechtfertigt. Das kann ich nicht bewerten. Ich war wirklich überrascht, weil ja, sie haben gegen Kiel verloren, aber davor haben sie ja trotz einer schwachen Auswärtsbilanz in Berlin gegen Hertha gewonnen. Also grundsätzlich ist alles so ganz in Ordnung, aber diese Unzufriedenheit darüber, dass man sich so früh aus dem Abstiegskampf verabschiedet hat, scheint halt punktuell um uns herum gegen Trainer-Diskussionen, also die volle Palette. Und meine Interpretation, auch die Stimmen der Spieler, unserer Spieler nach dem Spiel, war, dass du das antizipieren konntest und das gesagt worden ist, man wäre selbst ungern heute das Heimteam gewesen, weil es so unangenehm gewesen ist.
Die Region ist wütend.
Ja, offenbar. Also mich hat das nicht gestört.
Aber Anna, dann lass uns doch nach dem kleinen Ausflug Richtung Kaiserslautern, weil, also ja, Thorsten hat eben vorgelesen, spielte wie ein Absteiger. Du hast jetzt schon so ein bisschen die Vergangenheit, seitdem Lars Konnetka eben da ist. Was gibt dir denn Hoffnung auf ein weiteres Jahr 2. Liga? Weil ich glaube, man muss auch sagen, also keiner ist so gut auf Abstiegskampf vorbereitet wie du per se. Das ist überhaupt nicht despektierlich gemeint. Ich hoffe, du weißt, was ich damit meine. Denn man muss ja sagen, Eintracht Braunschweig findet sich mal wieder an der gleichen Stelle wie in den vergangenen Jahren eigentlich auch. Was gibt dir denn Hoffnung, was dieses Mal, also es hat ja auch in den letzten Jahren obviously immer gereicht, aber was gibt dir denn Hoffnung, dass es auch in diesem Jahr klappt?
Dass ich genau diesem Detail widersprechen wollen würde. Ich würde aus der Tatsache, dass wir verdient gewonnen haben, und das ist wirklich witzig, weil du das, also sowas erst nach dem Spiel sagen kannst, wenn du halt zu dem Schluss kommst, ja, du machst aus sehr wenig zwei Tore, aber du lässt auch unglaublich wenig zu. Es ist nicht so, das war, Kaiserslautern hat nicht gespielt wie Hertha. Das war nicht so, dass man gesagt hat, aiaiai, da hätte aber irgendwie der Videobeweis und hier der Posten und da die Latte. Sondern der Torhüter entschärft einen Kopfball und dann gibt es noch ein, zwei Situationen, die ja irgendwie ein bisschen heißer sind, aber ansonsten hast du das einfach gut im Griff, was halt in einem schrecklichen Spiel mündet. Und dieses im Griff haben in der Defensive hatte nicht zum Resultat einen guten Spielaufbau oder zweite Bälle waren auch. Das hat alles nicht gut funktioniert auf der einen Seite. Auf der anderen Seite, finde ich, verliert ein Absteiger dieses Spiel. Und mir gibt wirklich Hoffnung, dass ich den Eindruck habe, dass der Trainer, dessen erste Profi-Station das ist, er ist das erste Mal Chef-Trainer, er ist Co-Trainer von Ralph Rangnick in der österreichischen Nationalmannschaft. Das bleibt er auch über die Weltmeisterschaft hinweg tatsächlich. Und es ist völlig unklar, wie würde er sich schlagen, wie passt so seine Spielidee, seine Idee von Fußball nicht nur zu Eintracht Braunschweig, sondern auch zu Eintracht Braunschweig in dieser Situation. Und die Tatsache, dass er sich innerhalb von wenigen Spielen viel flexibler zeigt und viel weniger beharrt auf das, was er findet, wie Fußball gespielt werden muss, als der Trainer, den wir davor hatten. In Kombination damit, dass die Mannschaft wieder Fußball spielen möchte bis kann, glaube ich daran– ich hatte es gestern in der Aufnahme von unserem Gegenrade-Podcast gesagt –,Dass wir Kiel schlagen können und auch Dresden zu Hause. Das ist relativ weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt, das ist mir völlig klar. Aber auch da könnt ihr euch vielleicht ins Verhältnis setzen. Es gibt in solchen Saisons nicht so viele Spieltage, nach denen man ein bisschen mal laut sein kann. Oder an denen man gute Laune haben kann. Und deswegen sage ich das jetzt hier. So, 6 Punkte in den nächsten zwei Spielen.
Du weißt mit wem du hier sprichst.
Das wären ja tatsächlich auch meine Fragen gewesen. Du hast Kiel, Dresden und dann kommt Schalke. Wir gehen jetzt einfach mal zu einem Zeitpunkt aus. Schalke ist zu dem Zeitpunkt aufgestiegen. Schalke ist die Meisterschaft auch schon klar. Vielleicht kann man ja auch ein bisschen davon profitieren, dass dann eine Woche Malle oder so dazwischen war. Obwohl ich nicht glaube, dass eine… Also vielleicht zweimal bei Mäckis, aber in einer Mannschaft unter Miro Muslice. Also ich glaube, der will dann schon auch bis zum letzten Spiel das durchziehen. Aber ich finde das halt wirklich interessant, weil– also Anna, wir kennen uns jetzt auch schon ein bisschen und ich wage mich auch zu erinnern, wir haben schon so die eine oder andere Folge zum Saison-Endspurt aufgenommen und gefühlt habe ich dich aber auch einfach noch nie so positiv gehört. Also, dass du halt nicht nur dieses Jahr, wir müssen mal schauen, was der Rest macht und ob unsere Leistung reicht oder so, sondern auch diese, ja selber, diese Offensive, das ist dann ja auch was, was sich Lars Konnetka sehr schnell erarbeitet hat. Und das ist dann natürlich, also und dass du ja auch irgendwie das Gefühl hast, so wie ich das raushöre, man hat eben das Gefühl, dass was dann im Sommer passiert, da vielleicht werden da endlich mal die richtigen Weichen auch bestellt, weil man muss ja, also es ist dann ja trotzdem so ein bisschen Groundhog Day, weil du will, also trotzdem muss es dann jetzt ja mal klappen. Also ab irgendeinem Zeitpunkt muss Eintracht Braunschweig die Wege finden, weil also natürlich bist du die ganze Zeit 2. Liga und alleine deshalb, also das ist für Fernsehgelder schon mal gut, aber also auch da wäre ja schon mal ganz cool, dann vielleicht mal ein bisschen höher zu sein, weil Potenzial am Standort Eintracht Braunschweig ist ja weiterhin da, ne? Also, dass man und trotzdem– correct me if I'm wrong– aber es ist ja schon so, dass auch irgendwann aus dem Verein und aus den Fans heraus auch irgendwann mal dann diese Anforderungen in den Verein gestellt wird, so ey, jetzt mach doch aber auch mal was damit.
Ja, definitiv. Und ich glaube, was heilsam wäre, wäre wenigstens ab und zu so eine Saison wie Magdeburg in dem letzten Jahr, dass man das Gefühl hat, es passiert was. Und natürlich kann das danach wieder anders rumlaufen. Aber dass es überhaupt einen Trend gibt und dass der im besten Fall auch noch positiv ist. Und den kannst du aber bei uns leider nicht erkennen. Was auch daran liegt, ist, ja, das ist einfach. Also in dieser Saison haben wir im Unterschied zu der letzten Saison keinen Goalgetter. Rayon Philippe hat in der vergangenen Saison wesentlich dazu beigetragen, dass wir die Klasse halten konnten über den Umweg Relegation. Wo dort dann Christian Conté aufgeblüht ist, der dann ja auch maßgeblich dazu beigetragen hat, dass die Hinrunde ganz gut funktioniert hat, den du dann aber gehen lassen musstest. Nach Heidenheim, da hatte er noch ein halbes Jahr Vertrag und hat eineinhalb Millionen eingespült. Das ist natürlich ein gigantischer Posten. Aber Conté ist, obwohl er seit Dezember nicht mehr für André Braunschweig spielt, immer noch einer unserer besten Vorschützen und einer unserer besten Vorlagengeber. Und da siehst du halt, dass das, was verändert worden ist, also der Trainer, der jetzt in vielen Belangen eine ganz andere Herangehensweise hat, die ganz andere Ergebnisse nach sich zieht, aber diese Veränderung der Spielphilosophie nicht kompensieren kann, dass der Kader unterdurchschnittlich gut ist.
Also er ist besser als letzte Saison. Und du siehst auch Formkurven nach oben. Aber der Kader kann halt nicht kompensieren, dass er das Tor nicht trifft. Das ist halt irgendwie schwierig dann langfristig. Also, ja, gut, jetzt kommen wir wirklich hier in den großen Phrasenbereich, den ich nicht dreschen möchte. Aber auch das, du hast gefragt, was gibt mir Hoffnung. Faride Alidu hat getroffen, den wir lustigerweise aus Kaiserslautern für ein halbes Jahr geliehen haben. Und im Vorfeld wurde gesagt, ah, der steht im Kader. Naja, wir wissen alle, was passiert. Also nicht von Braunschweiger Seite, sondern von Lauterer Seite. Miatovic hat bei seinem nationalen Mannschaftseinsatz getroffen und im Spiel gegen Nürnberg, meine ich. Und ja, Demicci hat wieder getroffen gegen Kaiserslautern. Das heißt, die Stürmer sind grundsätzlich so ein... Also ich traue mich noch nicht, vom geplatzen Knoten zu sprechen. Aber vielleicht der Schnürsenkel, an dem so ein bisschen... Es ist kein Doppelknoten mehr in der Schleife. Da könnte man noch anknüpfen.
Es wird zu so einem Angler, so einem Seglerknoten, den man ja meistens sehr super kompliziert aufzubauen ist und den man ja eigentlich schnell wieder auflösen kann. Ja, ich finde, also wie gesagt, ich finde es wirklich sehr interessant, weil ich nämlich zustimmen würde, dass ich von... Also wenn man so ein Ranking erstellen müsste, von da unten drin, sehe ich eben Braunschweig schon in einer besseren Situation. Einfach weil... Also es kann ja am Ende dann trotzdem auch psychologisch ein wichtiger Faktor sein, zu wissen, okay, wir haben es halt in den vergangenen Jahren irgendwie immer geschafft. Auch wenn natürlich dann nicht gleicher Trainer, nicht immer die gleiche Mannschaft, aber das kann natürlich vielleicht im Endspurt auch von Fanseite einfach nochmal den Push geben. Und da bin ich tatsächlich sehr, sehr gespannt. Also wir haben eben gesagt, Kiel, Dresden, Schalke. Da sehe ich gerade in den ersten beiden Spielen. Und ich meine, man muss trotzdem bei allem sagen, also bis auf das Spiel gegen Münster hat Schalke ja auch durchaus auch noch Rückgründe, zum Teil seine Probleme mit Abschiebskandidaten gehabt, weil es einfach eine andere…
Hört, hört.
Ja, also ist natürlich auch für Frau Dona Lissendorf am Wochenende interessant. Also vielleicht schafft man es da auch, wie gesagt, dann trotzdem irgendwie Schalke 04 in den Unentschieden und so abzuringen. Und das könnte ja ein wichtiger Punkt, weil ich sage es hier auch gerne nochmal. Thematik, Torverhältnis, das spricht in der Gesamtkonstellation, gerade wenn du jetzt auf Magdeburg guckst, auf Bielefeld guckst, auf Dresden guckst, auch eventuell noch auf Kiel, jetzt nicht unbedingt für Braunschweig bei minus 16. Aber sie haben ja auf jeden Fall schonmal das bessere Torverhältnis gegenüber, für Münster und von Dona Lissendorf. Und das kann natürlich, gerade dass du eben noch zwei Partien hast, wo du jetzt nicht davon ausgehen kannst, dass du im Zweifel brutal abgeschossen wirst, sondern eben das auch irgendwann noch so ein psychologischer Faktor sein kann. Das wird dann natürlich schon eine ganz interessante Nummer eben raus. Ich bin wirklich, also ich glaube, wir drei sind uns einig. Abschießkampf ist wirklich, wirklich anstrengend. Und wir freuen uns wirklich ganz doll, wenn das vorbei ist. Und man muss ja auch einfach sagen, es macht es zum Teil doppelt schwer, weil ich liebe diese Oldstars-Gruppe. Aber man will ja zum einen, also ich wünsche keinem von euch, dass euer Verein absteigt. Einfach, weil ich ganz egoistisch gerne möchte, dass ihr in dieser Oldstars-Runde drin bleibt. Ich aber auch verstehen kann, wenn ihr sagt, hier, Alter, wenn wir nächstes Jahr 3. Liga gucken müssen, ziehe mir doch nicht noch diesen 2. Liga-Quatsch da rein. Und deshalb macht es das aus emotionaler Sicht auch mit Vereinen, wo man vielleicht jetzt im ersten Moment nicht denken würde, da hält man jetzt irgendwie emotional mit. Macht es das irgendwie noch mal doppelt anstrengend, weil ich sage das jetzt gerne noch mal, also in der unteren Tabellenhälfte Bielefeld, Braunschweig, Düsseldorf, Magdeburg führt. Ja, das ist äußerteam represented. Das macht es irgendwie nicht besser, ehrlich gesagt. Und wir haben alle unsere Sticheleien in der Gruppe, aber ich finde das trotzdem irgendwie, es ist irgendwie trotzdem auf beiden, ich glaube auch für die Ausstiegsmenschen, es ist irgendwie kollektiv trotzdem schön, gemeinsam zu leiden, gemeinsam sich auch zu gratulieren. Und ich sage das auch gerne noch mal, es freut mich sehr, dass wir uns zwischendurch auch immer wieder treffen in den Stadien. Es gibt immer fleißigen Bilderaustausch. Und das finde ich tatsächlich sehr schön und ich finde es sehr schade, wenn wir in der nächsten Saison deshalb Mitglieder dieser Gruppe verlieren. Das finde ich einfach nicht schön. Also, weiß ich nicht.
Jahrestreffen bei Hoffenheim 2.
Um Gottes Willen.
Och, och, also muss jetzt nicht. Außen muss jetzt nicht.
Das war vielleicht auch nicht ganz ernst gemeint.
Gut.
Gibt es sonst noch, Anna, etwas, was du zu Eintracht Braunschweig loswerden möchtest?
Ich glaube nicht tatsächlich. Was mir gerade noch eingefallen ist, ist natürlich Lino Tempelmann, der alte Schalker, der lange verletzt war und jetzt immer mehr fit ist und immer mehr Spielzeit schafft. Und der das durchaus auch noch mal verändert. Und ich finde, dadurch, dass im Winter weggegangen ist, Sven Köhler, der Kapitän Richtung Graz Hoppers Zürich, abgesehen von fußballerischer Qualität, du einfach gemerkt hast, diese Hierarchie, Disbalance, die einfach nicht eingepegelt ist, weil es niemanden gibt, der in dieser schwierigen Situation etwas tragen kann. Und dass es total wichtig ist, dass ein Faktor, der aushalten kann und dagegen hält und Verantwortung übernimmt und den Ball haben möchte, Christian Streich in diesem einen legendären Interview so schön gesagt hat. Also, ja, ich hoffe, ich täusche mich nicht. Ich finde, es gibt mehr Dinge, die uns Braunschweigern gerade Mut machen, als dass sie uns verzagen lassen sollten. Und bin einfach unglaublich gespannt, wie diese Liga ausgeht, weil ich kann auch nicht mehr. Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber ich kann auch nicht mehr. Dieser– also, wir haben Freitag gespielt, dann Samstag, okay. Aber sogar die Spiele, an denen man nicht beteiligt, das sind ja anstrengend. Das muss einfach jetzt aufhören. Ich habe auch keine Lust mehr.
Es ist halt ein großer Unterschied, finde ich, ob man als neutraler Zuschauer das einfach als Entertainment verfolgt oder wie wir jetzt wirklich sehr nah dran an den Vereinen sind. Und nah dran bedeutet dann manchmal auch persönlich, dass man Menschen kennt, Menschen kennt, um deren Jobs es geht, etc. Und das kriegt halt dann nochmal eine neue Ebene, ne? Das ist dann nicht mehr nur die Unterhaltungsebene, weil wir gucken alle Fußball zur Unterhaltung. Aber man kennt dann halt auch Menschen, die persönlich davon betroffen sind und ich sag mal, Spieler, Trainer, die fallen alle weich, aber vielleicht nicht normale Angestellte und so. Und das berührt mich dann tatsächlich am meisten. Und ich würde das gerne manchmal ausblenden, auch an den Nicht-Spieltagen. Aber im Moment fällt mir das persönlich super schwierig.
Ja, das ist vielleicht nicht mehr ein guter Schlusspunkt für diese Sendung. Also ich könnte mit euch immer noch gerne, aber trotzdem kommen wir mal zum Ende. Per se kann man glaube ich einfach echt sagen, ich stelle tatsächlich auch immer wieder fest, klar ist es auch nicht immer geil, irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, 400 Kilometer für eine 4.1-Klatsche zu fahren, aber ich stelle trotzdem immer wieder fest, was für ein Unterschied es macht, irgendwie live im Stadion zu sein und dann hat man trotzdem den Austausch mit Freundinnen, mit Bekannten oder du sitzt irgendwie nur vorm Fernseher und guckst dir das an. Da habe ich, wenn ich das vergleiche mit vor 3 oder 4 Jahren oder gerade so zu Corona-Zeiten, da ist schon ein wahnsinnig großer Unterschied und ich habe auch das Gefühl, es ist gleichzeitig so eine gewisse Gleichgültigkeit dann zum Teil drin, weil du denkst, ok, ich kann jetzt sowieso gerade nichts machen, also ich stehe jetzt hier und ich gebe alles irgendwie für den Verein zum Supporten, aber ich gucke halt auch nicht in die Leute, also in die Köpfe rein und trotzdem nimmt es einen ja auch irgendwie mit und wie gesagt, liebe Münsterfans, bitte nicht böse sehen, natürlich auch qua Revalität und natürlich auch qua Tabellensituation. Wenig da jetzt ich traurig rum, aber trotzdem kann ich das schon verstehen, wenn das dann, also Abschiebenskampf ist einfach scheiße und das tut einfach weh und von einem, wenn man dann wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Bekannten hat, die sagen, also es ist ja nur Fußball und das ist immer ein bisschen schwierig, weil es ist eben nicht nur Fußball. Und dann möchte ich aber auch diese Folge zum Ende bringen. Ich freue mich sehr, sehr, dass ihr beide Zeit gefunden habt, diese Liga mit mir zu besprechen, den Spieltag, die Vereine. Lieben Dank als erstes an Anna Lautenbach, die hier back-to-back dabei war. Danke, Anna.
Danke für die Einladung, war super. Und ich hoffe so doll, dass ich nächste Saison wieder mitmachen kann, einfach weil die Eintracht wieder mit dabei ist. Niemand weiß warum, aber es wäre so schön.
Und natürlich auch lieben Dank an Thorsten Wiese. Danke, Thorsten. Ich hoffe, dass du auch in– und dann hoffen wir mal, dass auch dein Streak im Rasenfunk erfolgreich weitergeht.
Ja, genau. Vielen Dank auch hier für die Einladung. Und ja, vielleicht gibt es ja Richtung Saisonende nochmal die Chance, diesen Streak zu überprüfen.
Schauen wir mal. Und sonst bedanke ich mich ganz recht herzlich fürs Zuhören. In zwei Wochen hört ihr mich dann mit Marc. Da geben wir euch dann ein Special. Was wird wichtig für den Endspurt bis dahin. Macht's gut, bleibt gesund und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.